so Tucker Carlson did an interview with
Russell Brand and he said something that
uh it might be shocking and it might
actually it's been it might be kind of
obvious there were a lot of feds on
January 6 embedded what Tucker Carlson
said was that he had done an interview
with the Capitol Police Chief who told
him this and he wasn't a conspiracist
and then he hears this is like
interesting he did not get a chance to
air that interview because Fox removed
him before he could he does intend to
have that interview so this is really
really fascinating I don't know if it's
necessarily a revelation because we've
been learning more and more about the
officers who were embedded on January
2nd even encouraging people to take
action but I still think this is a big
news I'm looking forward to seeing how
Tucker handles uh moving forward and we
do have a lot of other news too of
course we'll talk about that Donald
Trump heading to Dairy Queen buying
everybody blizzards having a good time
and then uh this may sadden all of you
leftists yes our leftist fans
AOC has endorsed Joe Biden
sure okay talk about an establishment
chill but fine we get it and then we'll
just talk about uh what's going on with
the the election stuff we got uh some
Ronda santis uh in the news and we're
gonna be talking a bit about that you
know this one's going to get silly but
um the DeSantis campaign used footage
that was produced by Tim cast news in a
text message that was sent out to a
bunch of people and an ad and the text
message was literally just our clip with
paid for by Rhonda Sanders on it and uh
that's generated controversy among the
Santa supporters who are screeching at
me because I simply said we did not
license this footage to them because
like I don't know what else I'm supposed
to say when they put when they text
people a clip like our clip and says
paid for by DeSantis and people are like
hey wow are you did you sell this to
them and I'm like no we didn't we didn't
license it and they're all losing their
minds so we're gonna have to talk about
it and let's talk about it before we get
started my friends head over to
castbrew.com and buy cast Brew Coffee
why it's our coffee company it's the
best coffee company I gotta be honest
this morning I had a glass of a cup of
rise with Roberto Jr man I can't figure
out which one I like better rise of the
Bruto junior or Appalachian nights but
they are both so amazing and uh you know
look we formulated these things these
Blends so of course it's our favorite
but I really do think some of the
highest quality stuff and and I hope you
enjoy coffee because then you will buy
casper.com and join our cast Brew Coffee
Club where you'll get three bags of
coffee every month supporting us uh this
is one way you can do it we're
sponsoring ourselves and we're launching
real world coffee shops it's just taken
a long time but they're coming also head
over to timcast.com click join us become
a member to support us directly and
you'll get access to our massive Library
hundreds of members only episodes and as
of recent you all calling in to ask our
our guests and ours and US questions so
definitely uh support us that way smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight talk about this and
so much more is James klug
thanks for having me what's going on
everyone James klug uh you can find my
YouTube channel youtube.com James k l u
g primarily focused on Street
conversations with folks on the left and
uh leftists out on the street everything
like that so you guys thank you so much
for having me right on and making a rare
appearance is producer Carter Banks
what's up guys I'm back
since the one time that I was on the
other time it's great to see everyone
he's been here to hang out what do you
do I make music and do trash house
record stuff we got a lot of stuff
coming up including a music video with
starring Ian Crossland that's going to
be that's going to be yeah we talked
about that last night very good
philibontius here hi everybody I am Phil
Avanti lead singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
and uh we're here with Ian Crossland
ladies and gentlemen welcome back have a
good evening tonight let's get started
we have to my right yes it is me hi
what's up everybody it's Kellen uh
pressing buttons tonight uh ready to go
and you guys are let's get it here's the
first story from the Daily Mail Tucker
Carlson tells Russell Brand he doesn't
know why he was fired by Fox News in his
first interview as he also makes the
bombshell claim that the crowd outside
the capitol on January 6 was filled with
federal agents well in fact we have that
clip green lives matter not sure who
that is other than
they have a good amount of followers and
they tweeted this Tucker says the chief
of Capitol Police told him that the
crowd on January 6 was filled with
federal agents he planned on airing the
interview but was canceled before he
could do so now we know why he was
canceled and fired are you seeing it
clearly now they don't want the world to
know the truth well let me play for you
that clip it's only about 50 seconds
along and that was a tip off to me I
mean I had no thought in my head as I
watched this happen on television and in
the subsequent weeks that U.S
law enforcement or military agencies had
anything to do with it that never
crossed my mind I never thought there
was it was a false flag or anything like
that I'm not a conspiracist by
temperament I never thought that
um and then I interviewed the chief of
the Capitol Police
Stephen's son in an interview that was
never aired on Fox by the way I was
fired before couldaire
um I I'm going to interview him again
but Stevenson was the totally
non-political
worked for Nancy Pelosi I mean this was
not some right-wing activist he was the
chief of the Capitol Police on January
6th and he said oh yeah yeah that crab
was filled
with federal agents what yes well he
would know of course because he was in
charge of security at the site
so the more time has passed now it's
been so that's that's the the gist of it
I mean this is
it's big news but I I do think it's
going to be better when Tucker does
actually interview the chief of police
and we hear it straight from you know
this individual who's in charge of
security but uh yeah I would imagine
he's gonna prompt uh you know actually
deliver that promise as well getting
that out there because that'll just be I
mean pretty much confirming a lot of
what people have been saying right after
January 6. I don't know if you guys
remember but I mean obviously this was
right after uh the summer of love and
everything like that in a a major
narrative just from people was uh well
Trump supporters don't really move like
that this seems a little bit off this
seems suspicious right it seems as
though the more time that's passing by
the more this stuff is just getting
exposed every single month the scary
thing I suppose is it's it's it's it's
trickling in drops at a time yeah you
know we we see videos of some guy saying
like go go go move and encouraging
people to engage in this stuff then we
learn that there's more and more police
officers who ran on the funny thing is
early on you had uh you have that famous
video with AOC where she's like I'm you
know questioning the cops who may have
been involved or she said something that
effect after uh Alex Stein did that big
booty latina thing she was saying like
we don't feel safe and stuff and the
point I made was wow AOC is claiming it
was an inside job but there's videos of
cops opening the doors for people waving
people in taking selfies with people so
right there you could argue yeah the
cops were letting people in if this was
really an Insurrection well they were
police officers letting them in yeah now
there's a bigger question and
increasingly more and more news being
added to the mix which is creating a
bigger picture of actually there were
people in the crowd encouraging it and
making it happen the reason why I say
it's scary is that it's coming out only
in slow droplets to the point where
people don't care because it's not a
bombshell yeah yeah just drop as many a
thousand stories over the next handful
years and like you said not a big
bombshell I think for the general
General like population as well they
don't grab on to the little tiny hints
and Clues here and there they really
grab onto major Bombshells so if I went
out and on the street and talked to
people about you know these details that
have been coming out most people don't
know about this stuff they only know
about major major explosions in the
media and then assuming that the
mainstream media even covers it and then
by the time we're at the general
election next year it will be common
knowledge that it was largely a federal
operation and they'll be saying it was a
good thing yeah it saved the election
help save democracy yeah first they'll
say first I said it wasn't happening
you're lying now we have more
information it was then they're going to
say oh well you're exaggerating and then
by next year it'll be a good thing
that's how the cycle goes and they'll be
like oh yeah it happened yeah and it was
a really good thing that it did because
they caught those evil people for sure
for sure yeah they they prevented a
Siege by letting them inside and
capturing them on the inside what would
the argument don't make what would have
happened if they if they tried to block
him I mean it would have been real maybe
they would burn it down you know so by
opening the door oh yeah and encouraging
him to do it was to find out who was
really going to be a a seditionist and
et cetera Etc blah blah blah I was
thinking a lot about these these
protesters last night and like they were
addressing grievances they didn't
believe the election was fair and they
were trying to stand their ground and
take space to prevent the signing of
basically the of Biden the of the
election they were like of you know
whatever they were signing off and
making it valid they were like no we're
gonna stay here so you can't they
weren't like attacking people or choking
people Ashley Babbitt got shot because
she went a little too far I think she
she climbing up in over the barricade
going into the inner Chambers got shot I
understand why I don't like it but they
were like just taking up space right not
to mention that had been done all over
the place for the last however many
hundreds of days like we watched in the
Summer of Love so they're like well I
mean
why can't we do this as well well they
they even try to sell it as an armed
Insurrection like they will go that far
uh I talk to people about this all the
time and they will go that far to be
like oh well some guy across the parking
lot was caught with a a firearm on his
person or something like that therefore
now they can say it's an armed
Insurrection like I was there man I was
I was reporting on the thing I was there
uh not inside I saw a lot of people and
it's like it was nothing like any right
you've ever seen it was it was okay some
people misbehaving over here you look to
your right and it's like 15 grandmas
praying I think there was uh there's a
photo of a guy who's on the stairs and
he's got a gun on him was he a Fed now
I'm starting to wonder this is exactly
the point well there's tens of thousands
of people there too so here's the issue
is that I remember seeing these photos
circulate mainly among the life a lot of
people in the right didn't know this
even I was wrong about this early on
when I was like there were no guns
already talking about how could you have
a gun in DC yeah they found a couple and
they did and now that we're learning
that there were law enforcement there
it's like oh now that kind of explains
it doesn't right like were those guys
because the question is how do you get a
firearm onto these ground into the city
under these grounds with heightened
security and stuff like that how did
they not spot this or find it it's
entirely possible I'm not saying I'm not
saying that they were law enforcement
totally possible some guy did bring up
bring a gun you it you can walk in you
can find ways to bypass security uh or
it could just be the photo they found of
that guy was because I don't think that
guy's been charged either well and
that's where it's like okay you raise a
very reasonable question your question
is who is that and even that gets
criticized it's oh stop that stop you
you're a conspiracy theorist don't have
this conversation don't get more
specific don't show more footage don't
educate people I should clear it up too
they weren't all I don't think they were
all just standing there taking up space
some of them were getting violent
pushing cops pushing breaking things
you're right yeah so those people I
think deserve to be punished for what
they did not for anything I mean you
can't just fight police and just get
away with it unless you're a BLM
protester right
it's not that much to ask to say you
know at least treat people fairly you
know but the same way that you would
that they treated the other protesters
in DC and six months earlier but this is
the point that Carter was making for
sure you have the Summer of Love
protests in riots in front of the White
House setting fire to St John's Church
forcing the president to a bunker and
the the half the people on January 6
were nowhere near that level for sure
there's so you know right injured uh
Secret Service as well they destroyed
multiple Patrol Vehicles like 100 or
something Secret Service were injured a
guard post was that was that on fire and
burned down right outside the barricades
were torn down yep the president was
forced into a bunker and so you get
people who are Marching peacefully to
the capital and first I always preface
it on one side violence very very bad
writing yep arrest those people and then
another side you had the cops open the
doors and say don't don't agree with it
but respect it and fan people into the
point where there have been acquittals
because there's video the cops going
like this and waving people in so you're
a guy watching Trump speak and then
someone says hey let's all go March down
to the capital and Trump says we're
gonna go peacefully uh you know uh watch
politicians you walk over you see a
building you see the cops waving people
and you walk in and they're like you are
now going to prison for the next several
years that charge or trial because
you're an insurrectionist after you just
watched all these videos of the far left
turn going to burn down a church in
front of the White House talk about it's
not even hypocrisy or double standard
who who was it who said Jacob maybe
there's it's a three-tier justice system
yeah he did he said it on the show when
he was guest hosting ah there's the
protected class then there's the random
run-of-the-mill people they care a
little about and the persecuted class so
if you're a regular person who's walking
down the street you may or may not get a
ticket they're going to ignore you it's
whatever if you're a leftist extremist
not only will you be acquitted like in
DC when they were riding during Trump's
inauguration they won a lawsuit and got
paid out by tax dollars and then if
you're a trump supporter you will bumble
around confused and you'll be in prison
for two years or if you're even
perceived to be a trump supporter or
whatever like Eric Herrera he went to
prison for actually I'll first say he
was uh non-credentialed journalist went
in there with a you know camera in into
the Capitol Building non-violent no
nothing violent that he did and he went
to prison for four years
prison for four years and I think he
went in
maybe three months ago non-violent you
you can even check out his case what was
he charged with uh so what they got a
lot of these people with and I you know
I'm not going to be I'm not a total
professional on this but I will say uh
when it comes to the charges what they
were getting people with was obstruction
of an of an official proceeding that's
what they got them on that is what they
were doing even though he was there
being a a journalist literally with a
DSLR around his neck um I believe he
like went into one of the offices and
held up a piece of paper I'm pretty sure
it says that on his case but he got four
years you can compare that to I mean how
many how many how many BLM or antifa uh
members can you compare that to from
riots that did something 15 20 30 times
worse that that served way less time
that's insane there are absolutely many
leftists who have been criminally
charged they've they often get
ridiculously light sentences there was
just news about people at a Michael
Knowles event some far left ex leftists
with explosives they've been criminally
charged you have those two lawyers in
New York who are giving out fire bombs
and what did they get like a year I
think they got like maybe two they
definitely got less than Eric I know
that and we had Matt Brenner in the show
talk about this bard
yeah I mean I would imagine too but I
wouldn't be shocked if we found out they
didn't though but uh Matt Brainerd was
on the show just a couple days ago and
he mentioned that there's a guy and
probably more than one that is currently
in jail without charge or trial two and
a half years later not charged with
anything so you ask what did they get
these people on well in some cases
nothing in some cases these people are
just locked up for nothing yep that's
crazy for having the wrong political
opinions being the wrong place in the
wrong time non-violent I I actually
forgot to mention also Eric to add on
top of this case he's actually a
registered Democrat as well oh wow so
he's not in that political of a guy not
even that political man yeah well let's
talk about this here uh multi-tiered
justice system with this story from the
Daily Mail green Jean-Pierre snaps at
the press for asking if the cocaine
belonged to Hunter or the Biden family
because uh what was the latest update
that it was actually near The Situation
Room in like a in like a family and like
high security area
White House Press Secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre snapped at a reporter who
had asked her to say once and for all
the cocaine found the White House did
not belong to a Biden family member I
just I love how it's like abiding family
member because everybody knows you're
not allowed to say his name you're not
the mainstream the media and all the
reporters are not allowed to say his
name basically you know there's been
some irresponsible reporting of the
family and so I've got to call that out
here press secretary said and I have
been very clear I was clear two days ago
when talking was over and over again and
as I was being asked the question as you
know the media Outlets reported this the
Biden family was not here they were not
here they were Camp David they were not
here Friday they were not here Saturday
they were not here Sunday they were not
even here Monday they came back on here
on Tuesday it's remarkable because like
Kareem they weren't there on Friday were
they there on Thursday oh and if they
were could Hunter have dropped his
cocaine then well okay yeah well I I
think them just not being transparent
about it or her not talking to Secret
Service or anything like that to
actually have some decent answers for
the reporters I I do love that we're the
point where No One Believes them I know
the reporters are just like come on yeah
like come on you know Hunter Biden's a
crackhead what do you expect is the
belief but uh in terms of jills we have
no clue but let's just be a Biden family
member I don't know for sure and Maybe
not maybe some senior official someone
connected but let's just pause and break
down January 6. bumbling guy walks
through doors opened for him by police
takes selfie with cops adheres to The
Velvet ropes as he walks around smiling
the police then say everyone's gotta go
and they go okay and they wave and leave
two years in prison
someone at a high level of government
bringing illicit drugs into the White
House ah we can't figure this one out
sorry everybody have a nice day how
about this whoever planted the pipe
bombs can't figure that one out either
yeah multi-chair multi-tiered justice
system I was this is a bit anecdotal but
I watched that video of Hunter on stage
with Jill and Joe from the July 4th
celebration where hunters look all he
looks all like tweaking pretty hard for
like a couple seconds and then he goes
behind Jill and I'm watching Joe's maybe
we can pull this video up watch Joe he
smiles real tense like
and Jill looks so just mortified right
when Hunter's behind her looks like he's
snorting coke off his wrist or something
or out of a vial and Joe like when his
arm goes up is when Joe goes like like
really awkward smile and Jill gets real
annoyed like oh God she can't stand that
guy hunter it's just so obvious I think
she said it plaintively in the past that
she I don't know to be honest I don't
have the documentation here but do you
guys remember that South Park episode
that's good I think it was from the 2008
election with McCain and Obama
probably and it's like the whole purpose
of running for president was it was a
diamond Heist to like race oh yeah yeah
and they're like boom baby it's like yes
I think it'd just be a really great
short film where it's like the Biden
family I don't like you make a show
people think it's like Veep but Veep is
silly but the Biden family is more like
degenerate you know like um what's that
what's that one show about House of
Cards no the family in Chicago that are
like Shameless Shameless yeah yeah just
like a bunch of degenerates and yes
that's like yeah you call it Shameless I
I didn't see that one but South Park's
been doing a pretty good job uh
especially on the Tran stuff they did a
pretty good job
man right yes right competing with the
Simpsons on some of this stuff well The
Simpsons are woke
uh I meant predict like for the
predicting of like the future well no I
just mean like relations The Simpsons
predicting things ended 20 years ago
right you know South Park still like
like five years ahead of the curve right
it's crazy are they predicting it or are
they giving it a green light I don't
think they're giving it a green light no
I think I think what happens with uh uh
you know if you watch a show like Black
Mirror not so much this latest season
because it's more of a horror series at
this point than a Sci-Fi series but it's
just a thought experiment it's a it's a
hypothetical like what happens if x
continues so when we're looking at
government like you just ask yourself a
logical question if Hunter Biden is a
crackhead I'm sure a lot of people could
have easily predicted we'll eventually
find drugs in the White House hey it
happened now we're supposed to believe
it was not Hunter he's the notorious
famous drug user so look maybe maybe
it's only a five percent chance it was
Hunter he still has the the dominant
plurality of probability The Narrative
is is already set either way like it
doesn't really matter if Hunter did have
it or not because it's not likely that
there's going to be any kind of
significant investigation the people on
the right have already made up their
mind that it was Hunter they're gonna
say it was Hunter and meme the hell out
of it even if it kind of sucks on him at
this point because he's getting blamed
for it anyway right I mean he's already
but he look there's there's video of him
smoking crack on his way to Las Vegas
driving 100 no no was it the same one
where he was driving 172 miles he was I
mean I heard the crack in the car was
different than the driving 107. does it
matter but the point the point that I'm
making is it doesn't matter because he
was going to Vegas to bang hookers he
definitely smokes a bunch of crack he's
definitely had Coke so like was it his
was it who is who cares he definitely
bangs hookers smokes crack and and dries
that is such a good point though you
know I think most of the American people
probably just draw that conclusion
anyways it doesn't matter what the truth
is at this point they just say okay well
uh cocaine yeah there you go he still
does all that right it just draws
attention to that yeah now here's the
thing about Hunter Vine like we are all
people who uh try to be to a certain
degree virtuous and we're like how dare
he driving such a highway smoking crack
but there are people who do nothing but
party and club and they're like whoa
like he's cool I don't want people to
think that I'm saying that I'm virtuous
responsibility I I've been in a band for
too long I have a history no if you go
to like the average person at a club on
a Friday Saturday night and you're like
let me tell you something about this guy
who drives like 170 miles an hour while
smoking crack and banging hookers
they're gonna be like damn like who's
this guy sounds like he can party it's
like the president's son they're gonna
go wow you're really going 170 was that
well I think I don't know like I think
it was in the in the phone doesn't
matter if it's 140 was he really going
he was going that fast I mean but the
point is like 30 miles an hour does it
really matter yeah no once you're up
over 98 I mean you're pretty much well
if you're over 120 I think it's one of
the most extreme differences is watching
how the media reported on Trump's
children and how intense I mean there
there was an article every single day
about this with Hunter you don't really
I mean you don't say his name dude
they're even saying of a Biden family
member it's like like who's it going to
be Jill right you know we know what
you're saying yeah but nobody's saying
his name nobody talks about him yeah
here's a photo booger sugar August 1st
2018 purports to show Hunter Biden
speeding to a Las Vegas
so is this video taken by him too I
guess because I tell you what NBC you're
right maybe it's not his cocaine in the
White House all the other stuff but no
but to be fair for even this like it's a
photo from his laptop most likely was
him but who knows maybe it was uh Devin
Archer or somebody somebody worked with
maybe it was Joe himself you know they
shared phone numbers or emails or
something like that and you know look
there's a lot of Highways out there
heading to Vegas where there's nothing
around and there's no speed limit so
technically he might not be actually
breaking the law because it goes by like
are you driving unsafe we know he had
cracked no he's definitely breaking the
law I'll stop with that one
Hunter's 2021 Memoir beautiful things he
admitted to crashing a Buick Verano
while speeding through Palm Springs
during another drug Bender in October
2016. wait man don't speak in the book
Hunter wrote that he was high for 12
consecutive days before entering an
Arizona rehab
it's unfortunate seeing people struggle
with addiction and all that stuff but
also at the same time you have the Biden
family that basically I mean if anything
they can pull this off I would say worse
than let's say this was the case for
Trump or something I mean they sell
themselves as the adults are back in
charge they're all responsible good uh
everybody says how good of a parent he
is you know who Hunter Biden uh uh Joe
Biden you know they sell him like this
good good good guy yeah
um that's just marketing caller Philly
Joe whatever right boys Joe Scranton
right and this is just uh hairy legs
it's not it's not a good look I got
compassion for the drug addict right I
often do but at the same time if my
military commander has a drug problem I
want them taken out of power I want
somebody else in command and if the
military commander has a son with a drug
problem and brings him around to the
military command spot which is the White
House that's a big problem for me or get
some really really high paying jobs as
well and prestigious positions or that
drug addicted son is sending text
messages saying you better do it or else
I'm going to tell my dad is going to
hold it again he's sitting right next to
me right now exactly exactly can we make
a show like can someone finance a Game
of Thrones style show called The bidens
because it would be a great TV show I
mean you could probably get if if you
didn't actually call it the bidens you
might be able to get something that's
true
we've got a show you know drama cells
show pitch okay I'm talking like two
million dollars per episode budget where
it was big deal HBO I hope you're
listening it's about a uh political
family
they cheat in an election to win
by having you know people go in late
hours and swap out boxes and stuff like
that then once they get in they start
doing Shady business deals to enrich
themselves think about it's Game of
Thrones in the modern era it writes
itself dragons
that's the name of the show chasing the
dragon just literally shot for shot
remake Game of Thrones but in a modern
context and the dragons would just be
like warships and stuff dragons are just
a TENS Birds
chasing the dragons and it's a war movie
kind of but it's about a corrupt
political establishment that's entangled
in some crazy war and drones that get
hacked that end up getting turned around
on the Homeland or something that'd be
wild and then what you got to do is you
got to have like the guy who becomes
president is this like decrepit
degenerate you know Alzheimer's
out of shape and disgusting and then his
rival who gets cheated has to be this
like tall chiseled and muscular blonde
man who sells real estate
that's right it's ice cream for people
every every season they find a way to
make the you know the leader just
collapse on the ground in some creative
way as well
yes it's every season like he's on one
of those like floors if he's gonna be in
the next season but he is I want to play
the Cliffhanger the hunter Biden
character in that I think I pulled off
it'd be like Jared Leto in in whatever
movies he does where he's like all
strung out or Memento I think that movie
was pretty good yeah are you looking to
do like method acts yeah
crackhead yes so let's strung let's talk
about what it means to be the left in
this country ladies and gentlemen from
CNN rep Alexandria ocasio-cortez
supports Biden's re-election bid
congratulations AOC is an establishment
chill that's what you get and uh of
course she's going to preface this a
little bit with like no I'm saying like
hypothetically I would if yeah yeah this
is what this is how politics goes AOC is
this young upstart who's challenging the
machine and as a real leftist then as
soon as she gets into office she starts
ponying up to the establishment you see
that video where like she changes her
Vote or something like that you know
it's been a while since I like Pelosi
yells at her and then her vote changes
or something I don't remember exactly
but here's the story because we want to
make sure the context is clear
Democratic Democratic rep AOC said
Thursday that she will support President
Joe Biden's re-election bid given the
challengers he currently faces in the
primary author Marion Williamson an
Environmental Lawyer and anti-vaccine
activist Robert F Kennedy have launched
campaigns when asked on the Pod save
America podcast whether she would back
Biden she said I believe given that
field yes
amazing there's your uh leftist there's
your new uh up and coming Progressive I
guarantee you in a few years she's gonna
start moving up people have talked about
maybe she'll run for Senate she got
millions of followers she is going to be
as establishment as establishment can be
she'll be coming out being like stop
insulting my banker friends the people
who run the Federal Reserve are good
people trying to make America she's
gonna be like Elizabeth Warren
yeah she's gonna just say whatever she's
going to say so the Press says something
positive and then she tricks people into
voting for she's already basically there
congratulations she's also super
valuable to the political Elite like
when it comes to the establishment her
her reach is insane she's incredibly
inspirational to a lot of young
left-wing women I mean our audience is
ridiculous I don't know partially you
can probably blame a part of the right
for doing that but she's really really
valuable for them so naturally I think
that direction and they would they would
give her as much power as she needs and
all that stuff because they want her
she's she's their establishment she's
their actual Pied Piper in that she's
playing that little flute and dancing
all the progressives right into the
hands of the neoliberal establishment
right you know it's an interesting
question because when AOC first won her
primary back I think it was like 2018. I
thought it was a good thing I was like
good get these establishment Democrat
chills out Crowley was a prominent like
uh fourth in line in the Democratic
party or whatever she she gets rid of
him she takes over and I said she may be
you know leftist or whatever but I'll
take a left populist over a corporatist
neolib shill and warmonger and what does
she turn out to be all that and worse
terminals any there's a problem as they
go in there get co-opted I don't even
blame her I blame the system itself we
need to turn on this because she should
be two and out yeah but you know what it
is it's AOC has nothing going for her
does she have Merit does she have talent
and ability to a certain degree answer
is yes but would she be anything other
than a bartender if she did not get
elected what we see with so many members
of Congress and politicians is that they
don't have the merits to do anything
other than win the beauty pageant and
once they do they're terrified look if I
don't win my re-election what happens
next right where's Madison cawthorne
right he's in the news every day he's
got something going for him he loses the
primary and now he's no longer relevant
so if you're someone who wants to be
who wants who wants to matter
and you don't have the ability politics
is your game and then what happens is
they get in and they're like okay I
can't lose this Nancy Pelosi probably
goes to AOC and says we will do
everything in our power to make sure you
lose unless you play ball
do you want to be the up-and-coming
young star of the democratic party or do
you want to go back to the bar and she's
like please Nancy I'll do anything you
say and here you go I know Matt Gates is
I don't know if these their their
friends or whatever but he's mentioned
to us that he would enjoy having her
come on the show with him at some point
desantises people won't even come on
this show she actually mentioned ilhan
Omar specifically I remember that and he
so they they have a bond of some sort
probably because they're young and in
Congress they're they're like all this
Freedom caucus and maybe they've worked
together a little bit as well as well I
would be shocked if she actually said
yes I would be really happy about it I'm
just thinking of ways to head it off at
the past before 20 years go by and she
is fully establishment that's scary like
job mentality she endorsed the Biden a
year and a half out come on yeah but uh
with a caveat that at this stage with
those two people that he's running
against I would what's her opposition
RFK I don't know well that's how you
know that they're full of it like
Newsome does announce too uh she would
go new you some for sure yeah yeah the
thing about RFK is um yeah I disagree
with them a lot of things but he's he's
he's more populist he's speaking to the
people and so it's like oh okay I get it
for her to be like oh man I'd rather
have Biden are you kidding you're gonna
have Biden come on warmonger
establishment come on man yeah I would
take Marion Williamson over both of them
to be completely honest I think she's
very nice oh she'd be a good guess we've
invited her several times she's actually
very very nice I have a lot of respect
for her I feel so bad for how the media
mistreats her and how people make fun of
her uh that's unfair she may be wrong
about things as most people are but she
she seems to be a genuine nice person
who really does want to make a
difference I think we would all benefit
from having that conversation with her
and she set the record straight about
crystals she doesn't actually own
crystals but but this is what I do but
this is how they
lady and it was so sad to see her be
like I don't understand I don't own any
crystals I've never done anything with
this why are they saying that about me
it's like welcome to the political Arena
yeah now now yeah Marianne where I'm a
fan everything bad they said about you
now think about what you think of Donald
Trump
welcome to the same game Donald Trump is
far from perfect and we know he said
some nasty things but when they come at
you and they say you're the crystal
woo-woo lady think about what they call
Donald Trump and how it's not real and
then people come out and they're like
but a court found that he was
responsible for a rape 30 years ago and
it's like dude spare me your Ultra
liberal New York District ruling that a
30 year old case with no evidence it
makes him responsible it's just these
are it's political nonsense yeah that's
the name of the game yeah it's always
interesting seeing people actually wake
up usually I mean I don't know if they
fully get out of it but her seeing how
she was treated by the media and just
kind of putting that or if she was on
the show definitely putting that into
perspective with her to say look at look
at what we're dealing with you dealt
with that for just a brief moment we
deal with that the right deals with that
every day right this unfair treatment
from the massive media machine Tulsi
gabbard's another one that had that big
time uh in the face of like what am I up
against totally woke up when they uh she
called out Kamala Harris and basically
tanked her opportunity to become
president if she ever even no but it was
before that it was it was Bernie yeah
yeah they called her a Russian asset and
she's like dude she's like a cur was
colonel in the middle they they viewed
her as an up-and-coming young star for
the Democratic party and then when it
came to Bernie versus Hillary said
Bernie and they were like you've just
ended your career and now she's like uh
Entertainer basically remember how she
called out Clinton Hillary Clinton she
called her like the ultimate warmonger
the queen of warmongers she like just
just absolutely you should call it
something or worse than that right yeah
it was it was re she excoriated her I
don't I don't have to find out the
actual quote right in front of me but
she absolutely escorted her it was one
of the most brilliant political one of
the most Brave political things that
I've ever seen anyone do someone
actually running on the Democratic
ticket calling Hillary Clinton it was
Queen of warmonger yeah queen of War
mongers literally just like carrying her
apart and after that when I saw that I
was like look she got terrible takes on
the two-way but I back her if she's
going after Clinton you know see the
this is what this is what I like right
we have uh we had we did the culture War
show today and we had uh Stephen Bonnell
uh bottle Destiny he's a liberal guy
um even after the show we were hanging
out and we were having disagreements but
Destiny is an honest guy he could be
wrong about something sometimes we all
are but I know that if we if we come and
have a conversation he's actually going
to try and make a point that he thinks
is true and honestly assess what we are
saying to him then you have the actual
cultural left which is people like AOC
who will just lie cheat and steal for
political power you have people like
Tulsi gabbard who was being honest in
what her views were and probably wrong
on something same as most people are but
was being honest to you on why she
thought those things and was genuinely
listening to you they're they're like
it's almost like
the culture War factions we always try
to Define what they are but I can tell
you one characteristic at the very least
is if you hold leftist political
opinions but tell the truth you're right
wing
plain and simple that's how it goes I
was actually talking with Destiny about
he said it was funny that um you know
when we do these shows with leftists
they make the Assumption of what my
political opinions are because in their
world if you don't follow their
narrative your right wing so they'll say
things like I'm pro-life or something
like that which is like I'm like none of
these like these things are not true you
don't know what my opinions actually are
these people make things up I mean come
on like what it would take to endorse
someone like Biden you know what I mean
and and for that matter I'm seeing a lot
of that with the with the DeSantis
people as well
I'll have a conversation with people
support Trump
and some people are fervently culty for
Trump and it and it is kind of creepy
yeah but most of the prominent Trump
people will absolutely concede Trump's
faults because it is the authentic and
appropriate way to approach the
conversation hey you don't like this
thing about Trump let me talk to you and
maybe convince you that there's still
some of that positives here the DeSantis
people it's like they're they're just
identical to Democrats no matter what
DeSantis does he is he is uh infallible
he's he's unimpeachable so descendants
makes a mistake and they will say it was
actually a good thing I wonder if the
people you're talking about we say the
DeSantis people you mean like people
that are following well and people in
this campaign hardcore followers on
Twitter maybe that I wonder if what
they're doing is it's like an AI or a
foreign agent sowing descent between
DeSantis and you because you have a show
and a voice so if they see some
contention they're gonna be like Oh I'm
gonna make Tim angry and be like to say
this is great you and then you you
think that it's the sadness is somehow
connected with that it is insane
responsible there's no way to know I do
because they have verification Badges
and profiles that say working for The
Descendants campaign those then maybe
but that's who I'm talking about that
seems like a a pretty big giveaway right
yeah and so when I said when I say
something semi-annocuous like wow I
can't believe this thing happened and
they start just attacking me on Twitter
I'm like what why are you attacking me
and so like well it's it's it's you get
the point it really does feel like they
are very much like
acting as Democrats do towards Trump
yeah it seems to me like they have like
a book of rules that they've written out
and studied but they don't really get
the nuances of why the rules work but
they're just following them all
expecting them to be you know to make
them cool in that way it's just like we
all see it's not working yeah it's like
a it's a list right you gotta check
every single box and if you differ such
as Destiny who probably differs a lot
from a lot of people on the left you're
kicked out of that cult when it comes to
the extreme left wing if you differ at
all you're completely out you know Tim I
was talking
um to one of your viewers the other day
I just ran into him in the street uh
libertarian kind of guy you know
disagrees with people on the right
disagrees with people on the left but he
was talking to leftist protesters gender
you know cold protesters and he was just
saying he was just asking them some
basic questions and you might agree with
them on some stuff but they were just
calling him a fascist and telling him to
get the hell out of there even though he
might have agreed on some things oh yeah
because it's a cult yeah let me let me I
want to pull this up from predict it and
we'll talk about Ron DeSantis Ron
desantis's polls have been on the
decline and his share is in the
prediction Market have declined around
30 plus percent over the past 30 days I
believe that Rhonda santis is an
excellent uh political leader in many
many ways and what we've been seeing
over the past 30 days has been very very
bad for him which requires a course
correction I'm a fan I'm a fan but his
his his campaigns failures and the
people who surround him have been so bad
I question whether or not he's actually
fit let me show you this one predicted
and we'll talk about what's going on
with us and DeSantis and the the desire
I guess from descended supporters for
there to be drama and for the tends to
lose support
so ever predict it you can take a look
at basically how this works is you can
buy a share of a candidate they're
called contracts and um who do you think
is going to win Donald Trump is at 56
cents that means if you buy yes and he
becomes the nominee your that share is
worth one dollar so you'll make you know
44 cents Rhonda Santos is at 23 cents
and he's declined quite a bit when you
take a look at the 30-day chart here for
DeSantis he was actually he peaked in
June on June 9th 35 cents and he's
dropped down now to 22 cents so it is
going down Vivek ramaswamy is popping up
this is the the example I want to give
to say this to the status campaign you
guys need to listen to the criticism and
course correct because right now what I
see is the Santa supporters are so
fervent and they're behaving very much
like Democrats to the point that if
Rhonda Sanders makes a mistake and
everyone surrounding him just says he's
right no matter what he will lose
support and that is what's happening
which brings me to the story that
happened just a few hours ago let's talk
about the Santa's campaign many of you
may be familiar with a video that went
viral where chanters in New York were
saying we're coming for your children
many of you are probably aware and some
of you may not be that that was filmed
by alad aliyahu our field reporter who
was specifically contracted to film for
Tim cast news that footage is property
copyright owned and licensed out by
timcast news to uh for for use a lot of
people have used it without permission
and there are questions about whether or
not they should have done that that
ultimately Falls to ilad aliyahu who
retains the rights for it for licensing
outside of timcast to certain degrees we
have we have an arrangement with him so
it's going to come down to whether or
not uh he he's he believes that we have
to pursue these things the Rhonda status
campaign took the the video nine seconds
of it
wrote paid for by The Descent of
DeSantis for president and started
texting it out to people
it's not an ad it's literally just the
clip that from from our Twitter that we
published and we own I did not go to
them screaming like I did I did speak
with people associated with The
Descendants campaign
um the first thing I did before any
communication happened is I get hit up
by a bunch of people saying did you sell
this footage to the status campaign
because I'm seeing this thing and I said
no we didn't I then have to talk to elad
because we have an arrangement where he
gets he he gets uh uh he gets paid
essentially a percentage based on
licensing we want him to make as much
money as possible when he produces these
things we want to promote him and
support his work so he gets that money
not us
if someone comes to me and says hey dude
you like I'm not saying this would
happen but this is what we you all need
to consider someone comes to me and says
hey I'm supposed to get paid when you
license this footage out this thing says
paid for by DeSantis for president did
you sell that footage and not tell me
because you'd owe me money if that was
the case I'm more proactive on that so I
said hey hey guys no like we didn't do
this what do I do I tweet we did not
license this footage to Rhonda Sanchez's
campaign all I tweeted that's it I did
not say how dare they they stole from me
who they owe me all this money I said we
didn't listen to them then people start
attacking me saying you're stupid you're
a people who write for various
conservative websites high profile
individuals and loads of millions of
followers people associated with Rhonda
Santos's campaign saying I was stupid I
was a more I was an idiot it's not how
it works how stupid is Tim Paul etc etc
these are not random people these are
high profile personality support
DeSantis and I'm sitting here confused
like yo all I said was we we didn't
license to them and so I tweet again I'm
like people aren't getting it they
tweeted out our video just just our
review nothing else saying paid for by
the test for president they're lying
they did not pay for this
and then people start claiming how dare
you they're saying that they paid for
the ad I'm like it's not an ad it's just
our video they're tweeting our video to
people and with with the tag on it paid
for by DeSantis there's no context
there's no statement there's nothing
added to it they wrote we're coming for
you for your children which is the quote
from the video with paid for by DeSantis
it doesn't say this is a commercial for
it stands for president we're seeking
your approval here's a clip you should
watch nothing it's literally just our
video
all I said was they didn't pay for it
the the the the absurdity and the
insanity that I see here is for one you
tweeted me all day and night about how
I'm stupid or whatever I don't get the
point do you want me as the Santa
supporters to go on to my show and just
insult his campaign because all it does
is generate hatred and animosity between
someone who otherwise should be
supporting DeSantis how about instead of
screaming and shrieking like banshees
you simply just say hey we're going to
reach out to you and um you know what
what's your what is your ask so I
actually reached out immediately after
after like I'm getting hit up by people
who are like hey they're using this
footage without without credit without
attribution and there's actually so like
we have lawyers there are questions
about whether or not a political
campaign can fair use news coverage
without attribution and minor sayings
they cannot even they can't make various
claims I didn't I didn't attack them I
didn't scream I don't mind I was like I
was like hey look man I got people
hitting me up asking me like if we sold
this to you because if we did I'm gonna
end up owing money to people so I don't
like that you guys are saying paid for
by DeSantis if it's just this clip and
they're like yeah no worries man like
we'll sort things out totally fine but
these people online is high profile
influencer support to Santa's it seems
like they're trying to burn his campaign
to the ground all they're doing is
trying to make it's like you were saying
I guess Ian you know I I would agree
with you to a certain extent it's almost
like they're Trump supporters pretending
to be the Santa supporters to hurt his
campaign
I would I tweeted that I would
ultimately believe it except some of the
people who have been coming at me in the
past literally do work for his campaign
so
all I can say is that that's where we're
at for now but the bigger picture here
outside of the personal context with us
is
these the the fervent zealotry and
supportive DeSantis is going to sink him
his polls are down his predicted Market
stuff is down yo if something happens
that makes a sentence looks look bad he
needs to be realistic and personable and
address it in an honest way and that's
how he wins but the course that they've
taken over the past 30 Days shows
exactly why the prediction Market is
showing a decline exactly wise polls are
dropping yeah did they at least use a
watermark on that nope
there's a lot of questions about it um
some people are like Tim said he wants
everybody to have it the other day and
he didn't care and I'm like there's a
difference between my opinion of this
should be seen by everybody that's why
we do it and I have an arrangement with
a contractor who retains rights over
that footage outside of what we want the
footage to be that has to be answered
for but even then I'm like you know
we're gonna talk with a lot and see how
he wants to handle a lot of these things
I'm not here to pick fights with
everybody just insult them but
there is a legal precedent my
understanding right now just just for
clarity's sake for the people who are
saying it when you see political
campaigns and it shows like a clip of a
news anchor saying a thing they show the
title of the segment or the or the date
and the publication they they have to
attribute it when they do these things
right and uh they certainly did not the
other thing people need to consider uh
so I can explain fairies to you guys
news organizations are largely exempt
from claims in this in this manner there
is uh varying degrees of arguments on
fair use okay
if you
if you produce a a News segment as a
news Organization for the purpose of
monetization and licensing people can't
just take it and use it
however if it's embedded on Twitter you
can use that embed in your articles and
that's what people do you cannot
download the footage and re-upload it to
your organization and some organizations
that we like conservative ones have done
this and yes we have been in discussion
of we're going to request licensing fees
for that so you know it's it's it's like
how do we be reasonable people in
support of those who would spread around
news that we want them to spread but
also make sure that uh I'll put it
simply
if an independent reporter covered this
footage if elod was working by himself
and did not work for us he would have
made substantially more money
we cannot have a reporter work for us
who is in the end making less money it
makes no sense
so as an independent reporter he has the
license to this he can go to anybody and
say you owe me X you owe me X you owe me
actually got to pay and he'll get it as
a large organization we front the cost
of the trip so that he reports under our
brand however
for what reason would he have to do that
if he's just going to say but then I
don't make any licensing fees no we
respond with we'll we'll let you retain
licensing fees and if we license it out
we'll we'll send that your way but we
get the effectively the brand
recognition so the important factor here
is it's not fair use when the footage is
produced specifically for the purpose of
Licensing and for news reporting there's
other arguments about if someone writes
an article or references things and
you're commenting on it directly totally
understand a degree and these things
have to be adjudicated a judge will
determine whether or not it was fierce
or not fair use is 100 always copyright
infringement it's just whether or not
you'll you'll fonder the exemption well
just just to be clear just my final
thoughts on this I am not saying my
demand is that DeSantis should have paid
me for this that is not what I'm saying
that maybe a large position all I'm
saying is people came to me and asked me
if we sold this to them because it says
on the video paid for by DeSantis I
understand people are saying political
ads reference that who it was paid for
legally and they're not saying that
video was paid for by him I am saying it
is creating confusion in the marketplace
and it's and so all I did was issue a
statement to clarify as I'm supposed to
do and I'm getting attacked by the Santa
supporters for it yeah and the
clarification's incredibly reasonable I
would say probably a lot of the backlash
is just people being completely ignorant
to the entire process of paying for
flights sending out a reporter or going
out there getting it all this stuff fair
use doesn't just mean somebody can spend
all that money and you can just cop it
and put it on your Cable News Network
without any credit at all without paying
anything like that I know you said it's
not about the money there but I think a
lot of people don't understand all that
goes into getting this footage and then
having it reasonably credited credited
as well I'm I'm personally not super
concerned about
um credit the money and stuff but that's
not my rights elad retains those rights
to a very large degree as per our
agreement with them which means
if he's seeing stuff he's produced be
sent far and wide
typically on his own when he reports he
sends an invoice like hey I own the
rights of this you got to pay for it now
he's he's operating under our Banner
that doesn't change so if he says he
wants licenses for this it's not whether
we want it to happen or not it's whether
he does and I think he's a reasonable
guy so we're not no one's trying to
start fights or anything I don't want to
too harp too much specifically on that
point other than to clarify it my point
in the bigger picture is
for the people who really like DeSantis
please look at the replies to my initial
tweet so you can understand exactly why
his polls are dropping is it it is an
absurdity for me to be alike we didn't
license his footage out and then just
have high profile people with a million
followers effectively you know just
insulting me for no reason
they could have been like thanks for the
clarification Tim that's it instead
they're just creating threads insulting
me like crazy so I'll tell you this if
your goal is to get me to really dislike
his campaign
okay I guess but simply put my opinion
on Ron DeSantis is not predicated upon
what his fans do or say
but the people associated with his
campaign who have also engaged in what I
would say is detrimental Behavior to his
campaign
what if I fear the reason why his polls
are dropping is because you're
surrounded by people that will defend
him no matter what he does
they'll keep telling me he's right no
matter what he does when the when the
video let's do this let's jump to this
story and we'll talk about this one we
have this from timcast.com gays against
groomers official resigns following
DeSantis ads slamming Trump's previous
lgbtq support
I actually I say to this very clearly I
I think Rhonda Santos does deserve
credit on going after the weird grooming
stuff and targeting of kids and to uh to
a great degree that that criticism of
Donald Trump is to a certain degree fair
I do think it is unfair to uh categorize
Donald Trump's support of your your
average LGBT person as the same as what
Rhonda census is fighting which is
groomers so there's a point to be made
there But ultimately there was backlash
Ronda Santos ended up getting flagged
from Log Cabin Republicans we now have
David Leatherwood announcing his
resignation from gays against rumors
because of the Ardent support the
organization's leader has for DeSantis
this has been not good for DeSantis The
Descendants campaign has been very
divisive on on many of these issues and
uh my ultimately my point is DeSantis
then goes on Tommy Lorenzo doubles down
on all of this
and what and the result is increased
backlash
Ron could have come out
clarified and said
maybe you were a little strong you know
I don't want I don't want to conflate
groomers with LGBT American citizens who
want to live their lives instead he goes
no it's totally fair for me to do this
Trump did this it seems like he's not
getting good advice that people aren't
explaining to him like Hey you have a
large Coalition of people who are LGBT
who support Donald Trump and will
support you because they may be gay but
they don't like the groomers don't
ostracize the people who do like you
but Ron goes for it anyway and it
results in stories like this
I think he's listening to sycophants and
it's hurting him
and it's it's tangible you see in the
polls yeah so what can we expect we
expect him not to win the primary do you
think that because Ron is looking to to
attack Trump from the right do you think
that the LGBT issues are going to be
something that he's not going to be able
to
get a broad message that his campaign
and his base will accept because I feel
like whoever is going to be the
Republican uh nominee needs to at least
tolerate LGBT people like like gay
people and and and probably trans people
to some degree obviously it needs to be
prevented from being you know instructed
to kids and needs to be taken out of
school curriculum and you don't want to
have it's the grooming stuff yeah the
grooming stuff so the political stuff
but do you think that the santis is
going to be able to lock that kind of
stuff down without without alienating
LGBT if gay people I think that's pretty
easy to
no it's not that it's hard but will he
be able to successfully do it yeah if
he's coming from the right you know if
Ron DeSantis is adamant on attacking
Trump from the right to lose
that that's just it and I think that
that's largely what it is
you know we were talking about this uh
downstairs you know we were uh we were
hanging out Sheamus Destiny uh John Doe
after the show and um we're talking
quite a bit about it
and I'm I'm like what we're seeing here
with the Trump versus DeSantis is
DeSantis really does represent the Old
Guard Republicans who are angry that
Trump stormed into their party and took
over and they see an opportunity with
the Santos to win it back
unfortunately it would seem that to a
great degree many of them lacked the
tact to pull it off yeah so the the the
the the zealotry the anger the I can do
no wrong attitude is exactly how you end
up losing this this internal yeah when
you're working against Donald Trump if
you want to defeat Donald Trump in an
election think of him as a non-Newtonian
fluid if you're familiar with these like
cornstarch and water right now the
harder you hit it the more solid it is
if you if you go slowly you use heat you
can push through it like a liquid that
is a that is a hard 20 and you roll the
20 right it's amazing I I see it exactly
this way the response from the DeSantis
campaign has been full force as hard as
possible and they're hitting a brick
wall but if they went slowly they'd
they'd slip right through if they're
response to a lot of these campaigns was
a lot of these these these issues was
just pure authenticity directly
assessing the issue talking to people
about their concerns and clarifying
issues they would be the status would be
defeating Trump in a prediction one way
I think that he could in once in one
second is that Phil to answer your
question can he pull it off can he can
he get the support of the lgbtq plus
Community yes if he Focus if he reminds
people straight people can be groomers
too it I'm I'm here to prevent grooming
of children I don't care who you are
what your sexuality is where you came
from what colors you love I don't care
don't groom these kids in my schools
that's I think the message because you
gotta you gotta push against the
straight people too that are grooming
and how how you know look yeah I I don't
unders I I perhaps the issue is DeSantis
believes he's in it for the primary and
that's all that matters which means
screw the moderates what he's ignoring
is that or and maybe they're trying to
recapture neocons one of the democratic
party I suppose I can't imagine how that
would that would make sense because a
lot of these Lincoln project people have
just embraced leftist values
Donald Trump brought moderates into the
Republican Party vox.com called Trump a
moderate so of course Trump came out in
support of lgbtq Americans that gay
marriage was a settled issue and that
was like a year after gay marriage
passed like right around this time so
Trump absolutely
attacked the Republican party from the
left in a lot of ways and it worked he
brought in many people who typically
wouldn't vote Republican who did with
the help of individuals like Scott
Pressler the Republican party was able
to to bring on more registered voters
than the Democrats in some states for
the first time ever the idea that you're
going to go back to how the Republican
party was before and attack Trump from
the right is a huge mistake what I was
saying about DeSantis a year ago the
opportunity he had was to be nice Trump
to talk about the same policies in the
same way but be tactful youthful and
energetic instead it seems like he's
taking the harder right approach which I
just see is not not viable yeah I think
maybe I'll be wrong most people see him
as like doing a fantastic job in Florida
of course a lot of people praise him for
that he did a fantastic job uh however
this so far from what we've seen him
interacting with the public and
everything like that one I think he's
surrounding himself with maybe not the
best people I I'm not gonna totally
generalize because I'm sure he's around
some great people but yeah just not a
lot not the best team and then also the
campaign I mean correct if I'm wrong but
it just seems like a glorified version
of low energy Jeb yeah it's it like
nothing about it's exciting nothing
about it I don't I don't I don't like
that you know a lot of people keep
trying to pull the Jeb card onto santis
I disagree you oh he's way better don't
get me wrong but but the campaign is is
more rabid than that yeah it seems like
he's trying to use trumpian tactics but
he's not Trump and he doesn't get that
he's not Trump yeah I might pull it off
right yeah and and the opportunity was
to not be the aggressive Trump but to
have Trump's policies now he's the main
Trump and now he's like
uh just attacking Trump and he's look
it's not so much the campaign but to a
certain degree people associate with the
campaign but for the most part it's it's
his his base whatever he's cultivated
for whatever reason our sycophants
he does something wrong what do they do
so what and I'm like well
that's not what we're I'm not interested
and to be fair Trump is this is very
very similar in that regard it doesn't
work 100 my personal feelings to win an
election is you make your opponents
irrelevant they're not the focus of your
campaign if you're if you're talking
about them you're giving them free
publicity this is what Hillary did to
Trump in 2016 she kept talking about
Donald Trump and how horrible he was and
kept giving him Fuel and perhaps that
sanus is doing the same thing perhaps
that's the goal the incentive supporters
want these stories to exist so that his
name gets mentioned more I suppose
I'll show you this over the predicted
Market Vivek ramaswamy take a look at
this entered the contract June 28th from
three cents now he's currently at eight
the vake is now in third place in the
prediction markets for the Republican
Presidential nomination he bypassed
everybody that's impressive Tim Scott
even this is this guy's not a politician
and he's a young guy yeah as soon as
people hear him speak just even for 10
seconds oh who's that guy I like that
you know they love listening to him so I
think just the more more people hear his
name hear him speak everything like that
that number is going to continue to
Skyrocket because what he's saying is
really resonating with the American
people yeah his message and regardless
of what actually happens for where he
lands uh in regards to actually running
or whatever
um just him being a part of the
conversation and the topics that he
brings up which make the other people
that are running at least and be
marginally informed which is one of the
things that I want a lot more out of
trump I want Trump to understand the the
policies that he's talking about because
I feel like a lot of the policies are
written by other people and he just kind
of is the guy selling them
um and so I think that it's really
really good that the vague is is you
know a third and he's going to be on the
uh on the stages he's really concerned
with getting money out of like BlackRock
and putting it into indexes that don't
invest in woke style or don't invest in
ESG particularly yeah right I don't know
if there's going to be stages oh you
don't think they'll do uh why would
Donald Trump debate Rhonda Sanders
clicks baby it used to be that you you
wanted a large platform to spread your
message we got it social media don't
need it
yeah I agree man 2006 I agreed with you
the age that old age of inner of debate
on a stage with a point hold on like the
moderator doesn't do anything anyway
that's done it ended in 2006 with
internet video now man drunk video in
2015 with something special yeah those
debates were something special it was uh
uh amazing no it was really amazing um
CNN would probably do pretty well in
something like that I still I mean like
you said you know so uh Trump will call
him Rama Swampy that's that I did not
come up with that song I can't remember
I'm sorry I did not give me credit for
something like that
um but you know to be honest he keeps
calling Ron DeSantis to Sanctus and it's
the stupidest nickname ever the
sanctimonia Ron does he calls him to
Sanctus now the Sanctus well the reason
it's not things change not working like
drastically in 2006 uh and I was
speaking internet video I was making
YouTube videos about it like now we have
the technology for world leaders to
communicate without Secret Service
present on through Skype uh they can
talk directly to constituents without
Secret Service present from their
bedroom any time of the day and CNN was
like oh hell yeah let's do the YouTube
CNN debates this time so in 2008 CNN got
their fingers into it and they had very
carefully curated videos from YouTubers
that they would give to the people
campaigning Obama Hillary Clinton and I
asked one about the Federal Reserve they
didn't use because they were carefully
of CNN you know curating it but you
could see that CNN was on their heels
they didn't know how to respond to this
new political populist up Uprising and
new technology and they still don't if
they think that I mean they didn't even
have debates last year for the last
election they didn't even debate they
didn't even debate what the first time
in American history that Biden did even
debate once I don't know yeah they
didn't the Democrats yeah they debates
but the Republican Democrat did he they
wanted more what they did too one yeah
there was one I remember being super
surprised about Biden being as on as he
was and I was almost like in disbelief
because oh yeah it was okay you know but
like to sleeping to think that three
debates is enough is like such an
Antiquated mentality they they should be
every week if there's two front running
candidates they should be for the
betterment of people of all of us of
humanity talking every week in public
which is a couple minutes ago saying
that it was good that there was not
going to be any debates and now you're
saying that there should be debates
every week well no I was saying that the
methodology of debate has changed
drastically since 2006 since internet
video appeared so like we don't have to
wait till they get on stage on Thursday
at 8 pm and they'll clap together like
the videos online forever because
they're talking smack on Twitter and
they can Skype they can debate over
Skype they don't need to even be in the
same room now so it's so easy to do it's
hardly the same thing though we really
need to see the debates I'd rather see a
Skype debate than no debate but I agree
with you having them in person is
important there are other people that
actually make up their minds after
watching a debate like actually waiting
for a debate and then saying okay I'm
gonna vote for that person are there
actually people that do that yeah I
think I think it's only slightly
different these days because of the
internet because you've heard the
messages because the news has been seen
ubiquitous
um I gotta be honest does anybody think
DeSantis can handle a debate with Donald
Trump
I don't know I don't imagine he could
personally I think I mean I think he
would do okay but but to answer your
question I mean no I don't I don't
really think anybody can not even the
moderators
I mean he is he's he's tough to take her
down yeah we made this point when we
were watching the primaries back in uh
it was like 2020 with the Democrats
Andrew Yang's might got turned off and
you see him just kind of like mouthing
but not doing anything and they're like
oh whoops and I was like if that was
Donald Trump he would lean over to the
other person like excuse me excuse me my
microphone is off you gotta turn it on
it's I I need to say it I think if
you're gonna beat it if you're gonna
beat Trump in a debate you need to
ignore him while he's bloviating and
while he's trying to insult you just be
like this and then keep talking about
what's important and just let him be
like like flames in the background from
the friction you know like it's but if
you try to him and start getting get
playing with his game with him you lose
because he's the best at it yeah you
don't want to don't engage with it I
don't know I know I don't know about not
engaging with it you need to understand
how to count dismiss it yeah to deflect
I think people just have no clue what to
do when he's in that zone because not
only does not only is he just coming
after you left and right right he also
oftentimes has the audience kind of
interested every everybody everybody's
honed in on what he's saying on his way
captivates I'll tell you this it's not a
debate this idea of a debate where I two
people say like let's discuss the merits
of you know uh us invent intervention in
Ukraine well I think the problem here is
but we have a treaty here like that's a
debate being on stage doing political
power is a show
one of the greatest shows on Earth and
Donald Trump wins the debate when he
makes you laugh at his opponent so you
can go on stage and Donald Trump can
talk about we're going to have the best
tax policy it's going to be very good
and then Ron can come out and be like
look I'm leading this comeback and I
think I did a better job nobody cares
it's When Donald Trump says
the sake this is a little bit he's a
meatball you know to be looking at me as
a meatball everyone's busting out
laughing anyway yeah he's a meatball
that gets the vote that that a lot of
people want to believe that the American
voter is above that but most are not a
lot of them are but you got to
understand this George Carlin said it
imagine how stupid the average person is
now realize that half of them are
stupider than that so if if Donald Trump
is looking at
a voting base of you know potential
let's say 175 million voters yet before
he's looking at total voter pool around
150 200 million
he knows that a hundred million of those
potential votes are going to be people
who are going to laugh about meatball
run and he does not need the smarter
people's votes because voter turnout is
low Donald Trump needs arguably 70 to 80
million votes in the general now now
again I don't slow down primary is a bit
different same same principle applies he
can sit there and be like I can make the
best argument in the world and win over
the top 10 percent of the bell curve or
I can make a joke and win over everyone
from 51 and down yeah I have mixed
feelings about that because you could go
the The Hard emotional gutting of Donald
Trump if you really want to play dirty
like talk about his daddy issues his dad
didn't love him his dad was like a
businessman that just treated him like a
commodity but you guys like you really
you could hurt him emotionally but like
but is that the way but you got to win
the hearts of the people too like
everyone's gonna be turned off by that
yeah look at him the reason he's the
reason he's lashing out is because he
doesn't his dad didn't love him and like
then the crowd's gonna be like oh and
then Donald's gonna be start getting red
in the face
look that is why it's not going to win
the hearts of the
you've got to make people feel good and
in a way that makes you look dominant so
when he was like low energy Jeb and
Jeb's like everybody bustling out
laughing and they're like yeah jump is
low energy look at him it's so funny it
makes Trump the bigger man in their mind
it makes them feel good at the same time
and they're like we need someone like
that to push people around for us yeah
someone that can fluster somebody you
could fluster Donald Trump well also you
have all these people like not in a way
that makes me like I'll put it this way
there are many people who could roast
Donald Trump and do and get it done
right Rhonda said this is not that guy
vivekama Swami is not that guy Tim Scott
is not that guy Nikki Haley certainly
not dead lady I don't see anybody in the
Republican field who's gonna have the
ability to make people feel like they're
strong they're good and Trump is
diminished at the same time Trump has
that unique ability he hasn't done very
well in the past couple of years in 2020
he could have done way better with his
body did a bad job with it that's why I
said 2016 2015 was something special
with the primaries and with Hillary uh
will we see it again from Trump maybe
it's out of him maybe maybe he's not
he's not all there we've seen a little
little bit of it come back but I'll tell
you this right now wherever Trump is
currently at in terms of his Showmanship
DeSantis is nowhere near that's just
reality yeah and if they if they get
offended by that to Santa supporters if
the Santa's campaign if they can't
handle that critique then they deserve
to lose if they listen to what we're
saying and right now begin to work on
that specifically they will win perhaps
yeah I think one problem with Biden that
Trump had and if he stays in that
everybody's gonna have with him is he's
a really hard guy to make a jab at
because like we were just talking about
something that makes people laugh it's
light-hearted all of that it's tough to
make fun and successfully deliver a jab
at a grandpa with dementia it just
doesn't look that good it looked a lot
better when he did it to Hillary Clinton
but not to Joe Biden people kind of feel
bad for Joe but I really think they do I
really think yeah I think Donald Trump
should have gone after Biden more so
than he did I think he did a relatively
bad job in 2020.
all that's great but I just don't think
it resonated as well as it did with
Hillary she was a lot more on her game
so when she when she gets she's shut
down it's way funnier than some guy that
can barely speak and she's nasty and
yeah she was kind of snaky yeah so when
Trump makes fun of her people laugh
that's a big factor I still think Trump
should have been like oh crazy Joe
what's that story Joe you're touching
little kids touching your legs gross
you're sleeping weird you're right Tim
it is a popularity contest and it's a
it's an entertainment game which is
terrible it shouldn't be that way for
the commander-in-chief of our military
it's been that way since TV was invented
like a radio yeah really TV will Hitler
use radio yeah I guess they had it
because the re the thing I'm talking
about is is when Nixon and uh JFK uh did
their first televised debate if you
listen to it on the radio people were
saying Nixon won if you watched it on TV
Nixon looked like a
he looked bad and everyone said that JFK
won so the way that people see you like
when the way you look when you're
actually in the debated it goes far
beyond just the the words that you say
and that's that speaks to the way that
we communicate more broadly people don't
just listen to the words the look on
your face matters if you're looking at
me in the eye all sorts of smiling all
sorts of things so when you're when
they're debating those things go into it
too Trump Trump's funny man he's
hilarious so when uh I went to the White
House for the social media some with
Bill ottman
I I don't know what to expect I thought
it was gonna be like kind of like a
round table thing what was it Trump
doing stand-up I'm not even kidding he's
got all of these influential people
sitting around I'm trying to talk about
the issue of censorship and he's just up
there speaking about it but it was like
it was
it was political humor it was political
comedy it was him talking about the
political issues and then snapping jokes
and looking and laughing and the room
was just laughing non-stop that's how
the dude commands an audience that's
that's how he wins you gotta like look
you can talk you sit here all day and
night back policy as the last twine it
wasn't the primer it's like good luck
with that dude good luck yeah but I'm
not saying Trump still got it though
we'll see it's yet to be seen you know
because if he might not even do a debate
my understanding is he's probably not
going to do a debate with DeSantis and
that's a good news for DeSantis but
maybe Trump can't handle it yeah I
wonder if they're they totally realize
that for his campaign Trump's campaign
just because you know how often he's
been going to restaurants buying
everybody food the the uh what are the
blizzards ordering everyone blizzards
all that stuff I wonder if they see that
really working and resonating with
people because you get that guy in a
crowd and like Tim's getting at he's
gonna perform he's going to perform as
long as he has a crowd around him people
are going to love him I feel like he
hasn't stopped doing rallies
get like since since the last time he
was President I feel like he's been out
there was a period where he was gone
okay yeah and then and then he's come
back and now he's been doing rallies and
they've been funny they've been funny
man it does feel like the only way to
defeat that kind of debate is to is to
under my is to really go at his personal
life like really hurt his feelings and I
do not like that but it's got it you
said defeat him at a debate he said yeah
if you want to make it look silly and
debase him make him off balance you make
him remember his horrible childhood the
problem is Trump weaponizes
self-deprecation this this idea that
you're going to insult his family and
when support is is wrong Trump calls Jeb
low energy he doesn't say he doesn't say
your father was a scumbag who like he
said you know well he said George W bush
your brother lied to us like that's not
the same as saying like you are you are
an abused child who is neglected and
that's why nobody loves you because
people go dude come on low blow he's
like you're low energy low energy and
people are laughing and they're like he
is please clap come on you could call
him low blood Trump like that's his
tactic as low blows but that's see the
issue is the delivery really matters as
well nobody delivers like Trump does so
you can get a jab in and that's great
and it can be spicy but you're not going
to land it Like Donald Trump but it's I
just I don't think it's going to work
right what can you insult Donald Trump
on his age his old man Trump is
a voice vibrant youngness
perhaps orange skin you you keep saying
that and you are you and I I will tell
you you're wrong I'll tell you why
because you'll be on the debate stage
and you'll say listen old man with your
moosed up quaff weird raccoon haircut
he'll be like certainly better than your
hair and that's saying a lot you should
call him and they'll say they'll say
you're an old man a black aging like
fight wide better than you you like milk
so go after him about how he drain the
swamp drain the swamp twamp I I can I
can help you Ron I can give you seeing
this episode
I Ian I appreciate it but Tim is spot on
Trump I mean he'll deflect he's a
professional Trump makes fun of him
made fun of himself for being orange he
was at a rally famously and he was like
the lights they're making me look too
Orange it's not fair and everyone busts
out laughing he knows how they insult
him and he uses it yeah but no one's
ever going after him with his
relationship with his dad yeah
it's meant to hurt his feelings and it
won't work make the other guy look bad
but like I mean how do you know that
that is something Fred Trump yeah I mean
okay just saying over and over again
they wouldn't shut up it had zero impact
yeah like if Donald Trump's gonna play
dirty and insult people then you better
expect you gotta get creative and insult
him I mean it's the only way is to hurt
his feelings that's it's also
entertaining what makes you think that
that is going to hurt his feelings I
mean that's that's because he hasn't
thought about it in a while and it's
true
your magic how do you know what he's
thought about like I'm trying to figure
out like how it is New York Times says
someone's familiar with his thinking so
what was that the New York Times written
many articles about people familiar with
his thinking that's what that's kind
that's what I'm coming for it's like
like I feel like you're you're making
these assertions but I don't know where
you're basing this this opinion of
Trump's internal monologue or is it his
internal like his sense of self-worth I
like but I don't know that that
would bring them to work and insult him
in front of people and and what's going
to happen is that's not funny that's not
meant to be funny it's meant to be
entertaining and that's the reason Trump
succeeds is because it is funny get it
well he's entertaining he's also a dirt
bag sometimes he's hilarious
other people's disgusting you know
everybody's entertaining no matter what
I say so he's looking to win over his
base you're not going Rhonda Santos is
not going to win voters by being this
nasty guy to insult a person who do it
very gently it's it's it and you move on
man you just let it resonate has anyone
seen that episode of SpongeBob where
they're like doing this talent show and
Squidward's out there doing this crazy
dance and no one is clapping but then
SpongeBob goes out there with a broom
and he's sweeping and everyone's like
going nuts that's what reminds me of
kind of like he might do something he
might say that and then people would
just be like you're kind of a jerk yeah
we're assuming that he would have a
strong solid delivery he would deliver
it kindly it would be a disaster one
because they sold Joe Biden or whoever
you're talking about here as being just
a kind person not Trump and then what he
comes out here with a nastier jab than
Donald Trump and he's talking about I
was talking about a DeSantis Trump
debate that's what I've been talking
about the whole time imagine oh sorry
sorry yeah yeah DeSantis um but well I
guess same thing applies then so if if
he's gonna deliver that and that's like
okay get tough on Donald Trump and be
mean to him and that's all great I I
don't see the benefit of really really
really being nasty to Donald Trump when
you're trying to win those voters keep
in mind it would be a jiu jitsu tactic
in that only if Trump won at him
personally or comes at me or comes at
someone personally then you maneuver it
to cause him emotional pain and then you
just continue on and let him shake you
know okay they they they all tried
coming at Trump and nobody could pull it
off because this is Trump's Arena the
idea that you're going to insult him and
win votes over is just it's absurd I
mean every Republic is excited during
the debates it's like 10 of them and
they all try yes doing this yeah yeah
that's how he insulted Jeb Bush he
insulted Hillary Clinton they insulted
all of them and there are MMA fighters
absolutely and they're MMA fighters who
are undefeated and you'll say well their
tactic is to use you know Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu so you got to use it against them
it's like oh that's funny they still
lost oh I agree with you that there are
no capable performers in in political in
the political Arena right now maybe AOC
maybe no Donald Trump's by far the most
entertaining whether you like him or not
um fast witty funny and in the right way
maybe Vivek actually Vivek Rama saw me
is way smarter and faster than Trump I I
you know what he he might on policy yes
I think it would actually be better if
we're if we're talking about just a
quick jab against Trump I think it would
probably be better than DeSantis maybe
agreed
I want you just to imagine this for a
second Donald Trump on stage and he says
you know we look at rad DeSantis little
Rana called him his policy is no good
disloyal and then Ron goes Donald
Trump's father didn't love him and would
ignore him so daddy issues over here has
a terrible time of understanding
everyone's going to be like whoa no you
say it directly to his face you look him
in the eyes and tell him you know and
and people are going to be like Boo dude
yeah they're gonna be like ah and then
it'll go viral 60 million views Trump's
going to do something so I got 10
million more votes you know this guy's a
boss
I I love how these things were tried and
all failed and you're like they'll
happen now it's like oh no I don't think
my problem is there's all the with your
with what you're you're thinking is that
you've got all this assumption and all
of there's a lot of like you're telling
this narrative about if you do this then
this will happen then this will happen
and the the possibilities are almost
infinite after step one like everybody's
plan like runs into reality and then it
falls apart and you're making so many
assumptions the reason I'm like what
you're thinking he's gonna do and what
people would do and what the Santas
could do and and just there's a lot of
like you to more telling a story than
actually thinking about something that's
realistic to try to navigate oh it's got
a plan until you get punched in the face
yes I've had some experiences where I've
had let me get to vote friends in the
past that would uh make fun of me or one
guy in particular and I was like stop
and he would never stop and then one day
I was just like your dad did not love
you and you turn into a real and
dude and and he stopped out he was like
shaking after and he never messed with
me again after that you were talking to
Trump no I was talking to my buddy and
his dad really did abuse him when he was
he was mean to him people call names and
stuff and like that's why you act like
this and he stopped after how many years
that a person would smack me and I was
like if you do that again I'm gonna
smack you back the exact same way and it
happened again and I did it and then I
never got smacked was he much bigger
than you it was a girl actually oh and
she never smacked me after that she was
hurting me so I was like please stop she
wouldn't stop for years they called
Donald Trump drumpf to insult his his
father's grandparents Etc that didn't
know is the tactics when they insult you
in the moment right away you strike back
in a way that makes them
okay out of the moment let's imagine
this they're trying to throw this guy in
prison and we think this is going to be
the thing that's gonna do they're not
gonna let him win I want you to imagine
Donald Trump calls Rhonda said this
little Ron little Ronnie's disloyal and
then Ron Emily turns him says your
father didn't love you everyone's gonna
be like what if you did it like a
starchy suit yeah but if he cried or
something then
yeah I was not gonna cry
it'll deflect off him like body armor or
something like it'll get all deflected
and it'll be nothing maybe we could talk
about it Trump's response is going to be
something like Ron will look and say you
know your father he didn't love you and
it clearly shows Donald Trump will start
laughing look at a little Rod over here
trying to come with my family it's sad
really is that the best you've got he's
gonna completely bounce off him and then
he's gonna be like the only thing the
sanderskin muster is insulting my dad
how sad disloyal not even loyal to
people's families it's exactly what
you'd expect when you vote for the swamp
this blah blah blah blah
like my point is this
Ron does not have nobody it's not about
Rhonda santis like no one in that field
of Wars at 16 GOP contenders could do
anything to get anything to stick to
this be like Rogan if Rogan did it to
Trump Rogan could humiliate Donald Trump
um bloody CK could humiliate Donald
Trump people like that you don't we
don't have a politician like you you
don't you agree with you there yes he
could humiliate Trump but in terms of
what Trump is working on fighting for
these things don't work against his base
they don't work against those who would
vote for him oh I disagree I think
they're cultists I think they go where
the hilarity is no let's say
you're you're Ian you you look the story
the story the story I told her
entertainment yes the story I told over
and over again my experience traveling
this country during Trump's first
campaign and his second campaign were
people saying I can't stand the way he
talks I wish he would stop tweeting
these the average person who voted for
him was not an occult and didn't and and
did not like his his Brash attitude
insulting him and the way he insults all
this does not work I've been hasn't
happened yet I think it's a bunch of
four channelers that want entertainment
they put them in office because they
thought it was funny it was a lalbert
move well that's not that's I mean
obviously that's not the case of who put
him in office it's not just a bunch of
4channers it was a lot of memes on 4chan
that got him elected not solely you're
right but there's a lot of like goofball
kids that were disaffected and were
making fun of the whole thing no it was
a lot of Americans that were sick and
tired of being called racist every
single election for the last decade and
they and they wanted something to change
and they were seeing Republicans doing
absolutely nothing when they get screwed
in every direction that's why people
voted for Donald Trump it wasn't just a
bunch of four chances it was not
monolithic it's a bunch of what you're
saying and what I'm saying kids like
Nick Fuentes that were like Hitler's he
would say like Hitler's he thinks Hitler
is funny because when he grew up he's so
disenfranchised by everything he just
looks at what triggers people and he's
like I'll do that because it triggers
all right I see what you're saying but
but that extreme part of a base that
you're talking about is much smaller
than I think you think it is nine
million Obama voters voted for Donald
Trump
they switched from the Democratic party
for Donald Trump
you think you're going to win a general
by attacking those individuals it ain't
working
but let's do this let's get cultural and
we'll we'll wrap up on a cultural
assignment we have the story from the
post millennial and it's good news
left-wing media seeds over success of
anti-child trafficking films sound of
Freedom the movie tells the story of Tim
Ballard all of you know it I'm a big fan
of the film it was it was absolutely
fantastic I recommend that you check it
out but oh boy
reports from left-wing news sites
Jezebel and the guardian have tried to
discredit the hit release sound of
Freedom linking it with conspiracy
theories
do we have the tweet from Jack was over
here let me show you this one
he says in plain sight
Rolling Stone says sound of Freedom the
Q Anon tinged Thriller about child
trafficking is designed to appeal to the
conscience of a conspiracy adult Boomer
and then there's from Rolling Stone
thanks to a major marketing mistake the
award-winning French movie cuties was
accused of sexualizing young girls it's
actually a sensitive portrait of growing
pains it deserves to be seen
that's who these people are
the groomers
yeah sound of freedom is doing really
really well and of course we're seeing
leftists get absolutely upset about it
but this is good news across the board
because it shows that we are winning on
cultural grounds we're winning on uh on
on in the Arts it's not about
conservatives winning it's about people
pushing back against the creepy woke
cult establishment garbage
um winning as a whole or just getting a
win winning as a whole
I just watched this if you look across
the board right
you can argue that the left holds let's
say you have you have a country and
there's like
12 jurisdict 12 battlefronts 12 counties
or jurisdictions and the right only
controls six of them they're winning
that fight gaining ground and spreading
even if the left holds more institutions
they are losing control of them I fair
and I don't want to sound too negative
right there I was just curious of what
you were talking about
um Target Starbucks sound of freedom for
sure for sure no no you're I mean we're
definitely on the offensive move right
now when it comes to people that just
are sick and tired of the like woke
Elite that dominates all these
institutions all of that
um I do have to admit I haven't seen the
movie yet well it just came out yeah I
am gonna watch it and I do know is it
not based on a true story true story
it's based on true story there's some
embellishments in it FBI am I getting
this uh Homeland Security Homeland
Security uh you might have been ice I'm
not sure in X right so he got out of it
and then quit because they he wanted to
save the kids and he couldn't you know
in working for the government right so
based on a true story and that appeals
to to Q Anon conspiracy theorists I mean
that's they just thought of that and
they said okay this is what we can do to
get the general population away from
this movie even though it's performing
really really well I mean it beat out
Indiana Jones on its opening day right
yeah Indiana Jones had opened over the
weekend and then it was a Tuesday that
this movie came out but it beated on
that Tuesday so it made like 10.8
million where Indiana Jones made like
10.7 or something like that still India
made 80 million over the weekend right
right that's still I mean it's still
doing fantastic obviously uh but that's
um that's a that's I I I think that they
really just wanted people to kind of not
dig into that story and that's not the
first time I've seen them bring up Q
Anon Rolling Stone yeah they weren't the
first people to to repeat that narrative
it's a Q on movie yeah I've seen it all
over Twitter I write like a bunch of
people are talking about making some
kind of connection to Q Anon um I don't
think that the average person like I
don't think Q Anon resonates with the
average person the people that have
about 15 minutes to watch the news a day
you know 20 minutes or whatever they
grab like they watch a little bit in the
morning a little bit in the evening when
they're doing their life
um I don't think Q Anon I think they
hear that and it's in one year out yeah
it was only because of outlets like this
that I knew what Q Anon was because I
heard it thrown around by people
tweeting stuff like that I'm like what
is this yeah but Panic um was anyone
talking about why Disney held on to this
movie for would they have the rights for
like five years I believe it was already
made five years ago for a sound of
Freedom yeah it was made five years ago
really yeah and uh well I can make some
assumptions as to why it couldn't get
released let's hear it because there are
groomers in Hollywood
and pedophiles in Hollywood and you make
a movie about ending child trafficking
and you'll end up with some Hollywood
executive being like Oh Haram if I say
but what about what I want to do when I
fly down there right
so um let's just say based on what we
know from uh some individuals who
produce documentaries about Hollywood's
the trafficking the abuse hey let's talk
about um Elliot page who claims to have
been uh assaulted you know uh in in this
industry
yeah they made a movie about child
trafficking being bad and wanting to end
it and then the big networks were like
the big studios were like uh oh we
shouldn't let people see this I'm gonna
go ahead and make an assumption as to
why that is yeah I was just watching RFK
Juniors uh interview with Lex Friedman
on Lex's Channel on YouTube and I saw
about half of it but at one point RFK
Junior was talking about project mocking
operation Mockingbird the CIA taking
control of the media in like the 60s and
70s then they were ordered I think it
was a church commission where they're
like you got to stop and they're like
okay but RFK was like I don't think they
really ever stopped and he was naming
Outlets that have been co-opted by the
CIA or that are assets Daily Beast was
the first one then he mentioned Rolling
Stone magazine yeah right away and then
I see Rolling Stones the one that's
trashing this ever since the 2012 ndaa
was signed the uh what is it the Smith
munt modernization Act uh was in the
ndaa and that made it legal for the
federal government to propagandize the
American people in nineteen after World
War II the smithmont ACT said that the
American population cannot be
propagandized by the federal government
and it was in response to what they had
learned that the the Nazis and the
Soviets had done before leading up to
and during World War World War II and
the federal government you know the
people were like look the federal
government shouldn't be making decisions
about what the people think right the
people the government should be a
reflection of the population not the
population or reflection of what the
government wants and that's borne out in
the way that governments have treated
their populations when their population
doesn't act the way the government wants
them or it doesn't behave the way they
want them to
um so that that the the Smith
modernization Act was in 2011 and ever
since like the narrative coming out of
the mainstream media has been the exact
narrative that the Democrats want you
had all of the time that Barack Obama
was the president basically setting up
this this app apparatus and then when
Donald Trump was elected the Deep the
Deep State the entrenched bureaucracy it
was already in place already prepared to
discredit anyone that would try to pull
back the power from the federal
government and obviously that's the you
know the conservatives if one of the
parties is going to make the government
smaller it is not going to be the
Democrats I'm not trying to convince
people that the Republicans are going to
be good or they're going to be you know
small government or random not that's
not the argument that I'm making but the
Govern the federal government has been
propagandizing the American people in
conjunction with rolling stone team
Vogue Cosmopolitan and again this is
something that I brought up on this on
the the show before you will get the
same type of uh stories in Cosmopolitan
in GQ in Teen Vogue in Good Housekeeping
and in probably in maybe not field in
stream but I wouldn't be all that
surprised because there is no
significant difference in opinion
because the narrative for almost all the
mainstream is the narrative that the
federal government wants to be presented
to the American people
that's the way that is that's the way
that I see it now Amen brother Teen
Vogue praising marks yeah I love it
that's hilarious did that actually that
actually happened it actually happens
what did they say they were talking
about was it like a month ago right no
that was a long time ago okay okay okay
yeah like Marx was misunderstood or
something like that it was actually
really really funny it's kind of it's
kind of scary you know you know but
funny at the same time Teen Vogue it's
like young women getting fashion advice
and information on uh supporting the
proletariat and overthrowing the uh the
the elites and the is this is this from
2018 Karl Marx the famed philosopher and
author of the Communist manifest can you
imagine years old can you imagine
calling like gerbils a famed philosopher
like
honestly like Marx is responsible for
millions and millions and dozens of
millions his ideas have were responsible
for dozens of millions of deaths in in
the in the 20th century at least the
word Infamous they should have said the
infamous philosopher no because
obviously is not enough Infamous is not
enough for me he's a terrible guy too
you guys are talking about it I almost
chimed in because yeah there's a lot of
like yeah Infamous is how you describe
like Al Capone not somebody's who's you
know ideology was the reason for dozens
of millions of deaths tens of millions
of deaths all around the world yeah and
it was just the idea that everyone
deserves a little bit it was the IDE it
was the idea that man can be perfected
because you cannot have a utopian
society where everybody works and puts
in and produces equally and gets out
right from the government equally what
so what the plan was was to remake man
into new socialist man that could be
considered a socialist man that is a
social being it was a very popular idea
in the late late part of the uh uh 18th
century I think it was 19th century
um yeah but it was it was Nichi was
talking about too because he had like
uber Mensch yeah the Uber mentioned the
Overman uh Thus Spoke zarathusion is the
book
um but the idea was that
you know Darwin had had put out his his
uh Origin of Species and and people were
understanding learning about Evolution
and starting to understand that and the
idea was we had conquered religion man
had conquered religion and man now could
understand science and we could use
science to remake man into the new man
that's the modern man that doesn't need
all the old uh you know the the old old
ways and the old religions and stuff and
it it just ends up with people dying and
mass because you can't make people not
people it sounds like you're talking
about transhumanism it well I mean it
transhumanism for that yeah it is an
extension of the same type of ideas but
the point of of of so the point of
socialism is to have a socialist world
like a communist world where nobody has
has anything more than someone else so
the abolishment of class right see the
abolishment of property so that way no
one has more than someone else and
everyone has e has equal things but the
problem is people have different
capabilities people are born with
different attributes people are taller
people are slower people are faster
people are the the they're infinitely
different so to think that people are
going to be able to put in and take out
equally is is ridiculous so the effort
to make people equal the only thing you
can do is take from the people that
succeed hold people down because if
you've got a person that's incapable of
doing something right just
good well that's incapable you can never
make them capable you have to find the
people that are capable and take and
take away their ability easiest way to
explain it is you can't make the grass
grow but you can't mow the lawn yep
that's perfect yeah right yeah and
that's what they do so cut off the Tall
Grass we're gonna go to super chats if
you already would you kindly smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends become
a member at timcast.com to support our
work directly and of course buy coffee
from us at castbrew.com I gotta say I
think it is some of the best coffee if
not the best coffee I've ever had and uh
you know it's easy for me to say because
we did the formulation for it as I often
say but I really think it's good so
support our work all right I'm not your
buddy guy says I think we can all agree
the left is far more extreme in the
right now that the right seems open to
separation I wonder what the left uh the
left with their lists want to do
interesting
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats
voice the people says the federal
involvement was exposed with the proud
voice case 50 plus Federal informants
were found instigating and judge told
the jury they can't use that information
to make a decision interesting wow full
Sensei says Tim in regards the video
from timcast news that Rhonda Santa said
he paid for it was paid for Rhonda said
has paid the editing guy to Overlay paid
for by Rhonda Sanderson that's actually
the argument they are making high
profile individuals with hunt with tens
of thousands and a million followers are
saying that the the edit to put that on
it was in fact what they paid for and
I'm like no comma yeah because if I paid
for a billboard and put your picture on
it and said paid for by me that would be
so disingenuous because I didn't pay you
for that image I just took it and used
it but it's like
it's just our video and it says paid for
but like it's just our video like what
are you like what that's the argument
they're making they're like well by by
adding the text that he paid for it it
is officially true that some they paid
for someone to do that it's like very
circuitous like there's no commentary on
it there's no like there's no statement
about it there's no commentary
whatsoever there's not even like a
gibberish so one of the arguments about
fair use this guy took photos from
people on Instagram
blew them up into big portraits and then
wrote a comment underneath it said like
hshshs like nonsense and a Court ruled
it was fair use it was fair use to in
fact do that
um despite the fact it was not really
any words or thoughts the argument was
that was commentary transforming the
piece
in this instance by all means you can
make the arguments because people often
like you'll always make an argument on
fair use they'll always have to the
point is they didn't even do that it's
literally just our video and it says it
says what the it's a text of what the
people said and it says paid for but you
know what it reminds me of is the real
Donald Trump ad where it shows fake
Donald Trump but it says real Donald
Trump but it's AI generated images it's
just misleading and this seems like it's
misleading because they didn't pay you
for the class and then and then the
response on the Deep fake thing was
people you think people actually believe
that was a real photo
do I believe I know people believed it
was real I'm not saying I did but
they're disingenuous and they're like
that doesn't mean that you they paid you
for it Tim I'm like yes but people think
it does because they're texting me
asking me if I sold this to them so I
hit up the sandwich people and I was
like Hey guys why is this happening and
they're like oh whoops yeah so I like my
conversation with the actual P like
actual people who worked there were like
let's try and figure something out I'm
like cool appreciate it but the people
online are insane so it's really funny
how like the end result might be that
they reach back out to me and say yeah
we'll we'll clarify for you man and you
know we'll send a license your way or
something a license fee and then and
then I'm like cool really appreciate
thanks for the support and the people
online turn it into this nightmarish
psychotic attack it's like okay make
yourselves look worse I guess right all
right we'll grab some more Super chats
what do we got based Jew says I've been
watching your skating Clips on Instagram
and damn you have that thing called
Diamond feet what is that diamond feet
uh just a couple of Clips we were
filming the other day I did a no slide
270 shove but it's like 120 degrees I'm
not exaggerating literally 120 degrees
inside the barn yeah whoa yeah it is
yeah yep it's just an oven and so it's
like when whenever I try and do this
trick because I've been trying to do a
bunch of things but it's just it's
brutally hot to try and skate in there
and that's our indoor park so I'm like
we gotta figure it's not insulated so we
can't like put AC in it or anything but
in between attempts of the trick I would
have to go outside to breathe because
the air was so hot you I couldn't
breathe that's how bad it was that's not
the half pipe room no no that's
downstairs and the the that's cold I'm
still seeing everything I saw James
dropping in on the skate park on Twitter
real James clue that's right man oh yeah
that's right oh yeah the small the small
ramp but um oh cool yeah dropped in
successfully didn't do much else other
than that but yeah that's proud of that
that's doing a thing
I didn't die and I put I put a helmet on
too just like smart yeah you gotta yeah
all right Crooked Smile says Tim why the
hate for Final Fantasy 16 was the
gameplay or the story please no spoilers
though the story is the most basic
one-dimensional kind of boring thing and
it it's kind of it's It's nonsensical
it's like honestly it's just really bad
and uh gameplay what gameplay wasn't it
mostly a story it's mostly cut scenes
yeah that's disappointing I'm not
kidding like the first part of the game
um it's it's a dejected storyline
timeline wise uh so it's a bit confusing
in that regard and uh it's mostly
cutscenes so uh mostly cut scenes and
then the most annoying thing is like in
typical video games you have the main
quest and then you have the side quests
Final Fantasy 16 has side quests but
they also force you to decide quests so
there are quests in the main storyline
that are absolutely side quests they
make you do where it's like you have to
run back and forth between two people
five times and I'm like why and and it's
just like hello Clive I would like to
tell you about what your father once
said to me and I'm like okay Skip Skip
Skip Skip then it's like okay I must go
talk to this guy now about the same
thing and then you run around the
building you find the guy and then he
just skip skip skip
it's like now I must go back and report
to to Auto what I found in you I'm like
why why I don't want to make a video
game like that now just for fun that and
you play one guy and I'm just like man
so people are saying yeah but it's it's
action it's not turn based anymore dude
Secret of Mana was was at was was action
uh RPG if that game is so good I know
and you switch between one of one of the
three characters you have and you can
have them do abilities and it's real
time fighting there have been a ton of
games that are real real hybrids of
real-time intern based with multiplayer
uh multiple multiple characters this
game is just you go into a fight and you
just Mash Square
and then you you match square and R1
that's the whole game the whole time
Final Fantasy is really known for a ton
of cutscenes though right like it would
be maybe a quarter of the game or half
the game even possibly is this one just
over the top as well I think this one's
over the top and that was funny because
people like Tim you're in story mode I
am not in story mode like I'm playing
Horizon zero Dawn and for forbidden West
uh so so forbidden West and the
expansion burning Shores came out I love
that game and it's got a bunch of woke
elements that I think are really just
annoying but it's like a good game
how do you defeat the bad guy like the
monsters in this game it's like well
they're giant robots so they have weak
spots you gotta knock armor off you have
different weapons of different elements
it's it's rather complex and you can
formulate different strategies for how
you do it I totally love going for the
sharpshot bow which is like sniper play
style when I play games like Fallout I
prefer you know sniper builds over
aggression builds or like tank builds or
anything like that Final Fantasy it's
it's like there's one sword you get
you never spend any money there's
there's no point in having money at all
none so it's just like I I beat a boss I
go to the forge upgrade sword that's it
the only thing you ever do sort of like
you you get item from bus
the story is so incredibly weak I just
went to look at gameplay footage while
you're talking and I the first three I
just clicked around randomly on the
video and the first three I went to were
all cutscenes and there's another cut
scene cutscene cutscene I cut scene
cutscene I'm not gonna spoil the game
but another cutscene I I could I could
have like I still think it's really weak
but I feel like I could have written a
better ending
uh because the like and that's not
saying a lot I'm not saying I'm a good
writer I'm saying the ending was so
incredibly one-dimensional comic book
villainy so like Golden Era like I'm the
villain yes what's happening at Disney
it's the same company name Square Enix
is a company that it's square and Enix
they've merged at some point but it's
not the same people that worked there in
1993 that made Final Fantasy you know
four that were Final Fantasy six these
these epic you know world-changing games
Final Fantasy VII was like one of the
greatest RPGs ever made yeah I think I
still have one for the super Super
Nintendo six but they call it a three in
the United States
no it was a similar guy that was the
same company square that was before they
merged with Enix I think yeah yeah uh
Chrono cross wasn't as good Secret of
Mana was multiplayer and then uh that
was one of the great it was like someone
else can control the other players and
then they uh this I don't think second
and setsu came out in the United States
but that was the next secret of mine
there were multiple games I think we
only got one
um I like the secret of Evermore was was
very similar these are action RPGs this
is all SNES right yeah oh yeah yeah it's
probably on super famicom yeah because
they didn't come out in the United
States but you know we got them we got
them because I love secret Romana so
much you got the ROM all right let's
read some more we got soul NATO says
Phil have you heard Anne Berlin's new EP
it's beautiful and gritty Stephen has
such a unique voice and I would highly
recommend it great work Tim no Luke I
puke no Hannah Claire I burn my hair
well all right have you heard the name I
have not heard it uh but I'll take a
listen Amber Lynn's gonna band right on
cool
let's grab some more Super chats
what is this
Luke MP says Tim please shout out my
neighbor Nicole Howell's GoFundMe it
won't let me share a link she'd been
battling cancer and they are struggling
to pay medical bills and their rent God
bless love you Ian oh let's see Emily
lose up Nicole hopefully uh I'm trying
to type it in Nicole Howell GoFundMe and
see if I can find it uh Nicole's is it
Nicole's medical and everyday expenses
nice perhaps I just think you know you
never know because there could be like a
bunch of different people but I searched
for it and it says she has breast cancer
and I don't know this person is what
I'll probably donate to him anyway
because they have cancer but uh yeah
shout out hopefully
um you know look guys this is kind of
why I'm more on the Universal Health
Care Camp of things because it's like I
just don't think that hey I'm dying
GoFundMe to support me is the is the way
we should handle it but I understand
it's a fair point that this is a private
Market where people can choose to
support someone if they want you know so
forcing people to donate isn't the
appropriate approach but I kind of lean
towards like I don't know if you know
like someone's dying so we go to
GoFundMe to try and save their life is
the right way we handle things also a
lot of these companies in the United
States they're using us to make their
money so they can give negotiated and
affordable prices to other countries as
well so we just get the short end of the
stick in every way shape and form yeah
why should go because someone's got
cancer
yeah you think like I'm an American
Medical Association would have a
donation process or something like that
at this point I mean no fees but the
American government would like the thing
is like it doesn't matter what the what
the thing is gofundme's taking 30 no I
don't know
is it way less depending on what what
it's for I believe they take a smaller
percentage if any percentage at all so
if it's if it's for cancer treatment I'm
pretty sure they have something for
lower I don't like GoFundMe as it is a
better one yeah you can take 2.9 plus 30
cents and some of that's unavoidable so
like even if you used to charge five
percent with our members like
there's no matter what you do they take
a cut is taken by credit cards excuse me
Drew outstanding in field says God's
children are not for sale Hill I'm
willing to die on here here yeah and
that's what I was saying about the movie
side of freedom is like even if you're
an atheist you understand the concept of
what it means say God's children the
idea that the media is like this is a
Christian film it's like dude you don't
need to be Christian to understand the
concept of God's children just means in
general the children of the world the
children of humanity you know I
understand Christians probably made it
much more literally but I'm saying like
the ideas in the film don't need
religion behind them for us to agree
that they're bad things but apparently
for Rolling Stone and a lot of these
companies man they really
that creepy people how many religious
movies as well look at the stamp of
approval from you know all these Elite
media companies in Hollywood and
everything like that I mean how you
could you could you know be listing that
off for a day but for this one I think
it's particularly offensive to them just
because of the issue that it's focused
on
yep I don't know well I think it it
infringes upon their predilections right
you know so that you know we can't
Hollywood can't be uh you know is it is
it is people someone someone commented
like Tim's waking up or something in
reference to me saying this and I'm like
dude I'm pretty sure everybody knows for
like a very long time that Hollywood has
been abusing children yeah like these
accusations been around for like a
decade
or longer probably but they've been
prominent for around that long
how old is Corey Haim right yeah exactly
seriously 50. I'd love to have him over
let's grab some more Super chats Feldman
Feldman's dead yeah oh yeah Corey
Feldman when I saw that when Corey
Feldman put that documentary out of paid
to watch it up we'll grab some
more here
97 says the best part of Kareem
jean-pierre's statement is that the
Biden family left the whitest around 6
30 p.m on Friday so when she's like
they're not here on Friday it's like
well you know they were most of the day
it's just lies it's all just lies yeah
all right survey sevi Rose says my
conspiracy theory since it's cocaine and
not crack I bet Jill Biden asked the
Secret Service to plant the cocaine in
the White House just to see how Hunter
would respond doctor feel good chill you
can call it doctor feel good now
Andrew ho says dan bongino gave a great
short breakdown saying it had to be uh a
protectee to bypass security in the
white house he should know being a
secret service on presidential detail
for Bush Jr and Obama exactly because I
was saying this too I was like someone
who doesn't need to go through the
normal screening process and and I'm
just some guy then Dan bongino said
basically I'm like hey look at him he
knows better than me he was actually
there so you know doctor take his word
for it yeah
where are we at also if they're changing
their story like three times before you
get yeah
there's something there's something
wrong
right Clint Torres says wasn't there
already a show called my son Hunter
I don't know huh
we will grab more it was a movie with um
wasn't it my son Hunter with uh oh yeah
Robert Davi right yes there was a movie
that came out oh yeah John James Jackie
says the show should be called the
Wilmington Hillbillies Hunter is Jethro
Naomi is Daisy May Jill as the spinster
from the bank
the Wilmington Hillbillies there you go
ask your says the coke will be blamed on
Kamala she resigns enter Newsome then
impeached Biden enter Newsome 2024 turns
into Newsome re-election
two circuitous you know what you don't
think he's gonna run I do but the idea
that they impeach Kamala appoint Newsom
then impeach Biden so Newsom becomes
president it's just absurd um well yeah
that's that's too many levels there yeah
they're gonna find a straighter path
than that yeah silver Knight says RFK
Junior will be the biggest bait and
switch in history don't drink the cool
lady still a Democrat when he runs
against Trump the media and all the
Democrats will fall right behind him
I wonder if that's the same for De Santa
stew the it's the zealotry that really
gets me
the people I you know resonated a lot
with were at the during the Trump years
was stop making me defend Trump because
like in 2018 and 19 I'm just like I'm
not voting for this guy I'm not a big
fan but seriously that's a lie okay you
know either things are critic I'm
critical of the guy over the economy is
doing well but like that's not true and
there were a lot of people I knew who
were like that and Trump supporters were
respectful of that position yeah
overwhelmingly they were like we get it
like as long as you're telling the truth
now you have the DeSantis people who are
acting just like Democrats twisting
lying smearing and playing dirty
manipulative games I don't have anything
to do with that and they're doing it to
RFK too so yeah so you if you think he's
a trojan horse check out that Lex
Friedman interview with him and see if
you still think that after an hour
well I think sorry I was just going to
say I think what a lot of people are
criticizing is like oh stop fawning over
him because he's still a liberal but I I
think to Tim's point or just in general
I think a lot of trump supporters don't
really care about that that much if
you're anti-establishment we kind of got
something in common there yeah Trump was
a liberal Democrat in the early days
anyway no one cared about this party
throwing my mind that he was Democrat on
the Democrat ticket
um didn't really see that after reading
some of those books and stuff RFK well
yeah but gun control stuff in the past
yeah I guess I didn't read enough yeah
yeah he's running as a Democrat for a
reason right or at least a lining that
right you know I dig the fact that like
the The Establishment doesn't like him
but that's where like the stuff that I
like about J uh RFK uh stops like all of
his policies like I I don't find
anything that's Liberty focused like
there's a lot of a lot of talk about the
libertarian party because he went to
pork fest and he spoke up there and it's
like wow he's not a Libertarian and and
you know it's like so if you're you know
a conservative or if you're small
government-minded that that's not
Kennedy at all so all right the
mafinator says it's almost as if Tim a
man who makes his living and runs
companies around making media content
would understand how copyright laws work
absolutely in fact not only that but uh
I actually made an app with a buddy of
mine 10 years ago called tagley which uh
we gotta bring back so uh you know Isaac
I hit you up we got to bring that back
what the app does is it's a camera app
and when you take a picture it instantly
includes time date location and custom
text you can customize what appears so
you can make it so that it only shows
the date only shows location only so
shows custom text store for some reason
none which you already have a camera so
you don't need to and it works on video
as well so you'd record a video save and
then it would instantly render the video
with within the bottom left corner the
you know time date location and all that
stuff so we got to bring that back uh
the point of that it also one one of the
components that was in the works was it
would create what is effectively these
days a crypto a cryptographic key at the
time we were all excited about this
technology where it would create a
digital fingerprint which would be
unique to the photo and it's like
effectively an nft uh and that was that
was the the intent was that
a reporter on the ground who takes a
photo or video would have definitive
proof uh and the means of of stamping
their videos instantly there are apps
where you can pull a photo in drag text
over type in what you want and then
press render right you can't do that
when you're on the ground filming stuff
right so we do want to bring this back
but my point is this not only do I know
how copyright law works I have
successfully uh sent cease and assist
letters and gotten content taken down
from people who have stolen uh my works
it's I've been doing this right for 10
years I've gotten paid
um I had one major Network send me
several checks for using my
footage.permission and it is really
simple often they'll use your footage
you'll send a letter saying thank you
for using my footage however you require
A license they respond with how much you
say here's my standard rate because you
didn't give permission I would like X
they say no problem sir the check is on
its way it's usually resolved very very
easily that's right what people don't
understand about fair use is they're
like I can take any news footage I want
and just use it okay you can't take
documentary footage from Netflix and
just upload it to Twitter
there you you can in some uh in some
circumstances fair use this fair use is
always copyright infringement and you
can always be taken to court over it and
then you need to justify why it was fair
use there is one big limit to fair use
when it comes to news did the person
produce the content specifically for the
purpose of Licensing out and and
distribution and if the answer is yes
there's no fair use sorry Getty uh at
Corpus which was purchased by Getty and
these other big uh uh these other big
libraries
you can't take a stock video from Getty
and say but it's fair use but AI even
even no they're getting sued over this I
hope so so I'll give you an example
there are many photographers who tweet
out their photos
and then license them to Major news
networks you will be sued in two seconds
if you touch that photo two seconds
because even though they published it on
Twitter they expect to sell a license
for it if it was true that you could
that you could fair use anyone's news
footage raw footage there would be no
independent or freelance reporters they
couldn't exist because anything you put
out would instantly just just get used
under the under fair use yeah there are
arguments to be made over what the
limits are so direct commentary on
things that are public do have strong
protections
my point ultimately with the copyright
thing to send us is I'm not even
literally saying that they should have
paid me I'm just saying like we didn't
do that arrangement with them that was
the clarification but there you go I I
love talking about uh copyright stuff I
have been in many legal circumstances
typically they never go to lawsuits and
uh usually they're they're resolved with
uh uh no problem man hey sorry this
happened and you know everyone's really
nice about it and they just write you a
check
so anyway
moving on
we'll grab some more Super chats RDC
says Vivek is awesome but he got in the
uh but if he got in there I believe he
would be sucker punched by the bat by
bad to the corruption actually is by how
bad it actually is and be roadblocked
like Trump was in 2016. I somewhat agree
but I don't completely agree I do think
he will reach he will face unexpected uh
conflict but I think he would not act
the same way I think Vivek would handle
it very very well
if you heard his story if you watch the
culture War podcast we did with him
this is a man in a mission
they besmirched his good name and honor
when he tried doing everything right
you know basically his story was that uh
they wanted him to write some like Pro
BLM thing and he wrote this fairly like
hey I hope we can come together and
overcome the stuff then they came to him
and said no that wasn't good enough do
more and he was like what are you like
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm doing it why are you
coming at me then they started attacking
him relentlessly people started
resigning and then he was like we've got
a very serious problem here right and so
it seems like two things happened he
recognizes this crisis in the United
States when it comes to ESG and wokeness
and he was personally offended so I
don't think he's gonna go into the White
House if he does which I think is a long
shot if if to say even a long shot I
don't think he goes into falls in the
same traps As Trump because Trump
thought he was going to be able to
compromise and be a typical president
but I do think Vivek will experience
things he doesn't expect because he's
not a politician yeah
we will grab some more Super chats Nuka
Taco says Phil every presidential
election has been a popularity contest
not just JFK George Washington Andrew
Jackson Ulysses S Grant Teddy Roosevelt
FDR just to name a few
that's right yeah I know did George
Washington run against somebody
my point about you were talking about
the show the the kind of yeah the way
that people saw when people can see the
actual people that are running like on
on a on a wide you know a broad uh it
was like the introduction of
entertainment yeah spectacle yeah you
still had stump speeches way back in the
day too and everyone there was you know
it used to be about like you'd read
about what they said in the newspaper
that was the majority of but considering
it's Democrat our presidents are demo
are at least somewhat democratically
elected they are almost all going to be
popularity contests because the popular
you know one is gonna probably get most
of the votes Ian I have to read this one
PK says Ian have you ever went the wrong
direction on the interstate and when you
realized it you just kept going
no oh my gosh I think I did that on a
road once
but pulled off I'm glad you pulled this
one yeah but Trump says I actually
believe that Joe Rogan could humiliate
Trump but not for lack of trying it's a
it's a Donald Trump thing not a Joe
Rogan thing
yeah I don't like it either I don't like
the humiliation but that's politics man
I see see the issue is let me explain
some of you guys when uh imagine a high
school class
and somebody farts then someone else
goes yo he farted he's like no I didn't
no I didn't and then everyone starts
laughing at the guy who farted right now
imagine the guy who goes hey everybody
check this out Lips This chica was
really loudly and then everyone goes oh
he starts busting out laughing being
like smell my fart you see the
difference is the guy who tries to hide
it is embarrassing happened the other
guy is subjecting you to it that's how I
see Trump Trump is the guy who subjects
you to his fart and laughs about it
seriously as opposed to the guy who
secretly tries to hide it wasn't me oh
no I'm so embarrassed how do you make
fun of a guy confident exactly yeah how
do you make fun of the guy who's wafting
it over at you and being like Revel in
it there's nothing you can do about it
you can't mock him for it he loves it
yeah that's why I go dirty
yeah does he get dirtier than fart jokes
yeah I go with their family life and
like try and really hurt their feel like
really hurt their emotions but I only
had to do it as a young kid because my
friends weren't talking about this again
my friends were brutal to me like
growing up they'd be like trying to
dominate you know and I'm like I'm not
I'm not letting me let you do that man
the reason you're doing it is because
you came from a broken home so stop
all right we'll grab uh one more War
Boss bad smack says Tim recommend you
try a game called Remnant From the Ashes
basically Dark Souls but with tree
monsters and guns we'll check it out all
right everybody if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel become a member at timcast.com
thanks Frank it's been a blast you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast James
you want to shout anything out yeah you
guys uh make sure to go subscribe over
on my YouTube channel youtube.com
James klug that's klug if you like
Street conversation videos and all that
great stuff you're gonna enjoy the
channel so go check that out you guys
thank you so much for having me right on
sup everyone you can follow me at Carter
banks on Twitter Carter banks4l on
Instagram and um follow trash House
Records on YouTube
Hillary Clinton is the queen of
warmongers embodiment of corruption and
personification of a rot what a lie yes
I love it personification of rot I
thought it was worse than just that it's
so good I am filibonti Philip remains on
Twitter Phil it remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can find us on Spotify Apple music
uh
uh YouTube Pandora you know the internet
and in case anyone's wondering that was
a Tulsi gabbard quote yeah you were
quoting that was not necessarily your
quote but I don't know if you agree with
it or not I definitely agree in
reference to Hillary Clinton I do agree
you heard it here first folks folks uh
also I want to give a special shout out
to sui Coden you guys ever play that
game it was another it was another
Square game back in the day suicodin 2
great game
console it was Super Nintendo well
actually they might have been on the
PlayStation it was on PlayStation
PlayStation yeah badass and also maybe
uh casper.com obviously we should do a
coffee taste test some night a little
little snifters of a bunch of different
things and sip sip I have Roberto Junior
this morning and it's like when I was
drinking the Appalachian nights I was
like this is the best coffee ever and
then this morning we switched to Roberto
Junior and I was like oh this is the
best coffee ever it's just they're both
castbrew.com I mean Crossland oh I just
I just I sincerely mean it like I can't
help but just Shug this coffee I I
haven't tried it yet um I'm definitely
gonna be trying it though yeah I want a
back to back some straight great black
coffee and uh the Sleepy Joe and the
unwell are coming really really oh then
we'll do the taste test when those
arrive that sounds fun bye guys I'm Ian
Crossing follow me anywhere on the
internet and we got Kellen yeah you guys
can follow me at Kellen PDL I want to
give a quick shout out last Friday we
had a Super Chat come through of uh Tim
Cass Community member that is coming out
with a video game when that game came
out today on Steam called drag the dead
so go support another Community member
of Tim cast and I think it's better than
like GoFundMe because you get something
out of it you get to play a game so that
came out today on Steam drag the dead
thanks guys
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out it's been a fun Friday night and
we'll see you all next time